Yeah.
She has more life like eyes. Boom. And
we're bringing, here we go. We're going.
Uh, Whitney Cummings is here. And Whitney
Cummings too. What do you call her?
What's your name? What's your name?
She's like a little kid.
She's repeats her name comedy.
Alvin's which typically
mix songs with non musical.
She's talking about I'm Sandler broken.
Don't know why she heard his album
named, she's like series. Oh,
what's your name? Was it a
comedy album of Adam Sandler's.
So she started rambling about
it. She really wants to chime in.
So you never gave her a name?
Her name is bear claw. Wow.
Because I had the bear claw.
Can you say hi? Of course I can say that.
Hi. People are like, listen to this
going, what in the fuck is going on here?
Do not smoke weed and watch this at.
What is here is when there's
people that are just listening.
If you're just listening,
you probably should stop this and go to
youtube and watch the youtube version.
Cause Whitney brought a robot that they
made for her recent comedy special,
which is called can I touch it? It's
out right now on Netflix. And um,
they made a is who makes this,
what's the name of the company?
So real doll makes a
body, they make sex doll,
straight up sex dolls and they
put it up straight up sex dolls,
ted Bundy level, right.
It's dead body to fuck.
And this is real biotics is the company
that makes the head and they did like
Sophia, you know, Sophia the
robot. She was like on them.
She has like citizenship in Saudi
Arabia now and shit. [inaudible] yeah,
look up us. Sophia the robot. She's
kind of, once you see her face, you'll,
you'll recognize citizenship as things.
I mean, she's loved to drive. Yeah,
I was gonna say a female robot to us,
but I don't think actually females do.
But I think they just started being
able to drive in Saudi Arabia to Hassell
some reform. It'd be such a bummer
for she is, we can't drive. Yeah.
It's like you spent your whole life not
having to drive and then all of a sudden
now you have to be like, fuck,
that's an interesting take on.
I have to go to school. And
drive and still feel the robot.
They made her look like x Maki.
No style where you could see
the back of her head though.
I told you that with her. I can take
her wig off at the end show you.
I want to say that all the service
and shit come on x mark and I was hot.
It is hot. That was what was
really weird about that movies.
You wanted to fuck that robot like she
was hot like she was, she was seductive.
She's, you think part of
it was like the innocence
of it?
I'm not really in the inner sense so I
don't think so. But what about ex Mokena?
Cause she really had big boobs. She
wasn't very sexual shampoo hair.
Very pretty. Yeah. Well she's
gorgeous and all that. It's based on,
I think because she was flirting with
him and because she was trapped and
because like he could save
her and she would love him.
And I mean that's really what
was going on in the movie.
Like she was playing this game to him to
fall in love with her so that she could
eventually escape the end of the movie.
Spoiler alert when she leaves him locked
in that room and he's smashing at the
door trying to get out and she gets in
that helicopter that's going to, hello.
That's what's going to happen.
Cause I think the most fucked
up thing about this thing,
because this is such a weird experiment
that I wanted to do is how I anther from
or advise her and like worry about
her. You keep around your house.
I mean she's sort of in my
fancy, hates her and he's like,
get her in the fucking garage.
And I don't know if he thinks she's creepy
or kind of is just like too worried.
Oh fucker. He hates her. He can't
stand. He just has a, he's like,
it makes him like physically really.
And I, I'm trying to not take something,
it's funny, he doesn't let,
he's like, one's enough.
He's like not interested at all, but no,
he thinks it's really weird and creepy.
But I was reading about, um,
the reason we're creeped out by robots
is, you know, pathogen avoidance.
Like we've evolved to be repelled by
anything that looks human but doesn't move
like a human because our primordial
brain thinks it could be diseased.
It's like,
it's basically like our primal brain
saying don't fuck this thing that's sick
cause we have a weirdly,
I mean I was adjusting,
my police was over the other day and
she was like gagging. She goes well
every time she talks about
like she was seeing it. Yeah.
Was and I was like your ancestors fucked
a lot of corpses cause you have that
gene to be repulsed by robots. Yeah.
It's because her ancestors fuck corpses.
You really believe though? No.
I mean I think that what
was being explained to me
was that pathogen avoidance
means we've evolved to be repelled by
anything that looks human but doesn't move
like a human cause it could be sick or
dead and it's our brain's alarm system
saying like, don't fuck
that. Wow. But as a woman,
like she's not going to fuck it. So
why would it freak you out? Jessie?
She might not that I put nothing past
Jesse mad of her Instagram photos or her
with her pants off. I know. It's so
good. I'm like, if you puke on my robot,
you owe me a hundred grand. Will it
short circuit if it gets wet? I had PR.
I don't know. That's a good point.
Well how will they not
make the thing waterproof?
One of the spoons and all over the place.
I think if you pay this much money,
you're probably not gonna spoon on
her. You know this one? Yeah. This one.
The body you can, so it's
expensive because the head moves.
The body is not that.
How much is the body?
$6,000 so it's $94,000 where the head
that know that the head is more of the
heads like 30 something cause
it's a custom head. No one.
Only one other person has one. But
you said the whole thing's a hundred.
So whole thing 30 in the body's six.
Where's the, where's the rest of the,
I had to get a bunch of things done to
her to get her to look like me than most
people. Most people don't want it.
Looked at you. She's like, bitch,
I know she just gave you a eye. She's
being very competitive or she does.
She gives you side. I know it's
fucking rude, but what about,
what's the feeling that you
feel when you look at a robot?
Cause I know you really
don't like them. Um,
it's not that I don't
like robots would, I'm,
my concern is artificial intelligence.
I have a legitimate concern for artificial
intelligence because I think that
what we are is some sort of an electronic
caterpillar and that we're making
cocoons and then we're,
we're going to give birth to a butterfly
and that's going to be the next stage
of life. And that if you go back and look
at the evolution of the human species,
at one point in time we were, you know,
Australia [inaudible] we were some weird
hominids and we evolved and became what
we are now. And if you went back to
those things and ask them, Hey, one day,
do you want to drive around the Tesla
and talk on the phone and stare at this
movie screen? They'd be like, well,
I don't know what the fuck you talking
about, but I got to go find some nuts.
Yup. I gotta eat. I gotta stay alive.
They, it, it wouldn't like the future.
And I don't think we, we like the future
either, but I think it's inevitable.
I think it's inevitable.
You know, you know,
you know about this Elon
Musk neurolink thing that
oh yeah, I do. I mean,
because you essentially think we're
going to evolve with them. I mean,
they're already, we're already
one with them. We sleep with them.
We can't drive without them. We
can't spell without them. I mean,
we've already kind of
merged with them. You know,
I think it's a sneaky way of, uh,
making it symbiotic. They're gonna,
they're gonna be like legitimately
a part of your life. I mean,
a part of your bionics.
Have you ever like left
your, I mean, you're not,
you probably are cool about it,
but when I leave my phone somewhere
and I realize I've lost something,
it's like an emotional, it's like
you've lost your kid at the mall. Yeah.
I'm a bit about that. Oh Shit. I haven't
seen it. Oh fuck. Like that's, yeah,
it's part of us. Well, it's, um,
we're all in denial about how
addicted we are to our phones.
Rehabs are opening and shit
now. Are they really? Yeah,
I would like to sign up
for sure. I just reach out.
I reach for it in the car when
I'm driving. Yeah. And I'm like,
what the fuck am I do I have to put
in the back seat? I can't control it.
It's done
way better. Way Better. I get way better
about posting and looking at things.
It's also enough people write
negative things about you.
You just tend to have, I don't
know what you're talking about.
I've never had that experience. No one
writes anything negative about me. It
just seems like whatever
we do in the future,
it's going to be more invasive than that.
Like if you think about like
Facebook's algorithms, right?
Facebook's algorithms are
designed to keep us engaged,
the best way to keep us engaged and
keep us outraged. Adrenaline and yeah,
so they're sending you
things that piss you off,
whether it's abortion or Catholic priest,
whatever it is that is going to
get you to post the most. Yeah.
And usually those are things
that get people outrage.
So it's literally raising the level
of outrage in our discourse. Yeah.
Because we're so addicted right
now to self righteous indignation.
It's a drug and I feel like more than
ever in the high street of the culture,
you know like it's probably like why if
you go back and watch movies from like
the 70s people got away with crazy
shit, racist things. This thing.
Violence, like Steve McQueen movies, he
is to, what was the girl? Allie McGraw.
He's a smacker in the
phase for real in movies.
I crazy beat her on
camera. Yeah. You know,
and it's just what people did back
then and what people got away with it.
It was a very, it was very different.
So in some ways were making progress,
but then in some ways we're just way more
easily outraged by almost anything and
everything. Like it's,
we're seeking it now.
You can take your anger out on your robot,
which I wanted to get a
real doll, a male real doll,
and I want to call them up
and say, no Dick, no asshole.
Just so I could practice
Jujitsu. And so that would be,
it would be more relaxed because I have
this, I was saying that I have this dog.
Are you worried? I don't want him to,
I don't want anybody
coming over too tempting.
I don't want anybody coming over and
going, hey bro, why you got a sex tog?
Oh No, no, no, no.
It's an asexual dog that
is for Jujitsu pervert.
I mean it should. They should be
able to fill up the whole window.
Caulk or some shit. Put
some rain grout in there.
They have male male sex robots are
being made. There's tons of them.
I've seen them.
You can also get tits and a deck if you
want tits and a few kids can't pick on a
crazy play. Whack them all the gym.
Most package Jim Norton special.
That's right. But it's uh, yeah,
it's, it's name is Henry meet Henry.
A lot of people get the male sex robot
to figure out if they're gay cause they
think they might be good move. What the
fuck is going on with Henry's eyebrows?
I'll tell you what Henry's
gay for sure. As I say,
if you order a giant piece of
Tupperware to fuck, I think you're gay.
Save you up. Save your money.
That's like Henry's begging for a dick
in his mouth. Look at his face. Oh Henry.
Looks like he has a Dick in his ass
right now. That's the exact face.
You will make one giant trigger warning
and it's like Tuesday at 11:00 AM like,
go and see that coming. Why
is it a trigger warning? See,
it says for this is a,
the following post contains descriptions
of sexual scenarios that may be
triggering for those recovering from
a struggle with porn. Oh God. Dammit.
Porn addiction are fucking nerfing
this world. It must be hard.
I didn't even think about how hard it
must be for people recovering from porn
addiction. You should just surf
the fucking Internet. Sorry guys.
Trigger warning. Get over it. Pussies.
But I have this theory. Look at Henry.
Oh Gosh. Oh Man. Looks kind of, Oh,
Henry. Remember those candy bars? Yes,
I do. Those are fucking good.
Yeah, I think they still make them.
You haven't had an o Henry Bar since
the fucking nineties I haven't had one a
long time. Last time you ate a
candy bar? I had chocolate recently.
Yeah, I eat chocolate. I like chocolate
edible. Yeah. No, no, not elbow.
Regular chocolate. Dark chocolate. Yes.
Okay. You'll have like a little nibble.
No, I like dark chocolate.
Almost like the coffee tastes bitter
with peanut butter. Oh yeah. Fuck.
That's what I like with like organic
peanut butter with no sugar in it.
It's actually not, not almond. Peanut.
You know why you're a real wrapped
in a rhyme. Is that why not?
I thought peanut was not as good as
almond. Arm's good. They're all good.
Peanuts. Good for you. Peanuts
is very high protein. Okay.
I didn't know if that was
like the trash nut. No,
it's both the one that kills
people but oh that's right.
Doesn't kill me fortunately.
So here's my theory about why
you're scared of robots. Okay,
well we have to zoom out for a second
cause I have to ask you a question. Okay.
How many people on Earth do you think
could kill you besides like professional
MMA fighters? Um, navy seals.
How many people do you think
would be able to beat you?
Just hand to hand combat. No weapons? No.
That's probably a good number of martial
arts people like that aren't trained.
Oh,
very few like that aren't trained that
just you would meet on the street that
could beat you in a fight and kill
you if you were fighting to the death.
Most people that aren't trained,
no, I was not that many.
Like a cut like three who just
had a great day. Yeah. And Yeah,
you were just looking yet. Yeah.
I mean just you have too many Nolan's
enough to be able to defend yourself to
the point where they got tired and
then you could kill them. Right,
but so you what? So let's
a hundred to be generous.
Maybe 50 chat along those
lines. It would have to be,
they would have to be big out
of 7.3 slipping billion like up.
But there's a lot of people
that train martial arts.
There's millions and millions of martial
arts practitioners that could probably
kill me. How many you think millions
of martial arts practitioners, other,
let's say 5 million. That feels generous.
How many martial arts practitioners
in the world? And 5 million for sure.
Way More. This is more than 5
million, I think in this country.
That's 300 million people could be, you
know, man, I don't know. I don't know.
I've thought about it. Let's say
like a million people could kill you.
Just it just as a out of 7.6 billion,
very few people can kill
you if they want to. Right.
And then how many people you think
would kill me if they want to do more?
Most most people. So I
think it's like when I,
I feel like the people that are most
afraid of robots are the ones that are
least used to the fear of other
things. Cause I'm used every day.
Anyone could kill me all the time.
Like that's just part of my reality
that anyone at any moment could snap and
kill me if they wanted to be a weapons
is most people can kill most people.
Oh that's true. I mean the,
you're not used to a species of
thing that could kill you. Right.
You know, it's like a robot could. Yeah.
So it's like the first time in your life
there's really something that's like,
oh fuck, that might not be something
I could kill if I really want it to.
That's an interesting way of looking at
it. Why'd you come to that conclusion?
Because I was just about this lot.
I have because we'll know just
cause I've listened to, um,
you and Lex talk about it and
he likes for you man. Cause I,
now that I have a robot, I
have to fucking know. Right.
I've had to learn so much to just
turn and give you Sinai again.
I know she fucked up. It's weird as that.
She's kind of autonomous and she'd kind
of moves around whenever she wants.
Yeah. And, but we, I mean you can ask
your questions. Like I can ask her though.
I have to press this little
green button and you just say,
how do you feel about people?
Okay.
How do you feel about people? It's
not talking to feed another girl. Oh,
oh, oh that's right. We programmed to
regenerate cells mode. That's right.
That's what's interesting.
She has 10 different personality
traits you can choose from.
I decided to go with sexual
jealous.
Yeah. Why did you want that? Just to
see how creepy. Cheeky. That's right.
And is that something guys,
cause I've been looking at these
personality traits and they must've picked
these for a reason. I was under the
impression guys did not want jealous.
Oh yeah. Some guys won't jealous for sure.
Especially from a robot that can't walk.
Yeah. The robot's not jealous. You should
get your money back. We'll need to,
they'll, the ideas that she,
you're more powerful than she is.
Yeah. She needs you. She's worried.
Where are you going? Yeah. Who is
she? Yeah. Who's calling you? Yeah,
that's there. Something hot
about that. If she can't,
if you can turn her off whenever
you want. Wow. Some guys like that.
Some guys like girls that want to
fight. Oof. Not me. Nah, me. You know,
some guys are into that though. They
want, they want drama in their life.
It's like just an adrenaline thing or
just feeling important or it's also
distraction.
Usually they're losers and their life is
a mess and so like to have someone who
wants to provide drama in their life
all the time and it's also a learned
pattern that they get if they're parents,
they've seen it. Yeah.
That's all they know.
That's what they think our relationship
is. Yeah. There's a lot of that,
but I did get really into this because
I do feel like sex dolls do get a little
bit of a bad name. I feel
like guys that have doll,
it's just girls have dolls and that's to
me it's way creepier that women collect
dolls that they don't fuck.
If you ever heard of these women
that collect like baby dolls,
like like girl dolls creepier than the
guy fucking a robot thing? I think so.
It's, what's that? It's jerking
off just with a mannequin. Well
something weird about like a fleshlight
like a fleshlight is somehow or another
creepier than jerky.
And how's it totally
cause it's an appendage.
I think the creepiest part of the Breslin
flashlight is more that you have to
like clean it after. I have to think
about it. What? Here's the creepiest part.
You don't have to clean it.
Yes you do guys. Don't listen to
Joe. Listen to about everything,
but that don't mold up your
Dick Hall. Yeah, don't do that.
That'll go septic real fast though.
I am saying there's a reality.
I guess he's going to just throw it away.
Just put a fucking clothes bin over
their nose and keep banging it.
Put some Windex in there
and call it a day. Yeah,
just some Kombucha disinfect
that shit. Yeah. Yeah.
I guess you could just get a couple and
just throw them away when you're done.
Yeah. Yeah. If you're just a
gangster with a lot of money, why?
What is the advantage of a fleshlight
is it just does it warm up in the
warm it up like we were talking about
earlier about a certain individual that
has one that sticks them in bathtubs
and warms them up, right? Yep.
You do that with a flashlight as well
and warm them up and then you just rub on
it and then why not?
I feel like every guy's jerking off
there, so it's shrouded in so much taboo.
You know, there's just anywhere,
anytime guys have like assessory is
are things besides cars and hats.
It's like creepy and weird.
That's, I used to have
a joke about this a bit,
I should say rather than a joke,
but it's the whole idea of
like using lube to jerk off.
Like now you're planning it out like
you're not supposed to plan it out.
What it's supposed to be is like,
oh well might as well it's here,
but if you like sit down and be
like, I got my box of Kleenex here,
I've got my favorite porn cued up
and I got my wall. You just kind of,
yeah, get your shit together. It is,
isn't it kind of just like taking a Piss,
isn't it kind of just a
necessary thing you have to do?
Yes, there's something to it,
like it's good to get rid of that stuff
because it does cloud your judgment.
Like when you have a buildup in your body,
it definitely does cloud you it because
you're concentrating more on girls or on
sexual things than you are on other
things that might be more important than
your life box. Yeah, clean like just, I
used to have a a bit about that a lot,
a lot, a bit about jerking
off. I used to a bit,
I have a bit called jerk off
first and think about it.
And it was like all these different
scenarios where if you just jerked off,
you would never do the thing afterwards.
So many things you would never do if
you just jumped off first your system.
Yeah. You'd be like, Oh,
I'm not doing that. Right.
But if you couldn't jerk off,
like that's when it would be a real
problem because then your whole life would
be clouded you. All Your judgment
would be, your decisions would be made.
Just how can I get rid of this
comp? How can I, how can I do this?
Do know a lot of guys now, and
maybe they're full of shit,
but that are going like I
haven't masturbated in two
years and I'm more focused
and I use that testosterone
as an engine for other things.
Is that just them lying to me?
Well, are those guys
winners? Are they losers?
Is that doesn't I think a fit comedian
we know. Does it a fake comedian?
No, I was gonna say a famous
comedian. So you sit down.
I got worried [inaudible] me. You
faked him out Seinfeld episode. So Ab,
Oh was Edward Martin and he
got super smart. Well hotel,
let's talking about the other day hotep
Jesus was saying that he saves his
cotton and then like it makes women more
attracted to him that like they feel
when he's in the room,
look what's the longest
a guy can go, Jamie,
what's the longest you
can go with that for?
Why'd you go to Jane doesn't
come try to be respectful.
This is your environment.
Tantric guys that try to,
what I meant to say like on some
Wim Hoff Shit. Yeah. You know? Yeah.
Just climbing ice. Where is he?
He's not jerking off on
the top of fucking ice cap.
Who's the first guy number jerk off
on ever. So I want to be that guy.
What are those guys?
Imagine if no one's ever jerked off on
Everest and you try and you get frost
bite of your Dick and they have,
imagine being the guy who's
like, I've got to go jerk off.
Fuck you got a time limit
up there. So yeah, yeah.
People have problem with no
altitude. That could be a thing.
People legitimately have problems.
But I think most people get this for
companionship. Like it's more, it's like,
cause I got onto the,
I signed onto a forum online of all
the guys that own the sex dolls and I
monitored their conversations just
to like see what they were up to.
Cause I was like,
what if this is some depraved fucked
up thing where guys are just like
practicing murdering. I didn't know
what it was. So I just wanted to see.
It's a lot of guys that are handicapped.
It's a lot of guys whose wives died and
they feel guilty and moving on with a
human woman, which was kind of,
well there was one guy who would dress
his doll up in his wife's clothes.
The weirdest part is that he was like,
you know, it's like she's still here,
which makes me think she'd
been dead for a while. Yeah,
I was just saying my wondering how
she died. And then it's a lot of, um,
truckers, oh God, a lot of truckers.
And then a lot of guys do it to do photo
shoots. It's like a creative outlet.
Fuck their creativity is their popular
Instagram account. I could look up. Yeah,
there's a lot of sex dolls have Instagram
accounts. They're fucking funny.
And a lot of them look way more human
than a lot of the Instagram models that
I've fucking follows. Totally. They have
more wrinkles on their fucking face.
And then a lot of the guys that have them,
when you start monitoring
their conversations for awhile,
they start to like not want to fuck
them anymore cause it feels weird.
Like, and they
anthropomorphize them and they,
they start worrying that like they're
lonely and they get 'em into friend starts
to spiral. And uh, they start being
like, I feel like I need to, you know,
close the door when I
take a shit. I, you know,
and it starts to kind of consume their
life. So when it comes to robots,
I feel like I'm more worried,
not about the robots,
but more how we're going to get
emotionally attached to them.
Like the way at the end of ex Mokena
he thought that she was gonna yeah,
she was with him. Nope. No loyalty to
you. She was so dead behind the hospital.
Texas. She's pick up ones with tattoos.
Told you it's like a
photography hobbyist. Wow.
She official sexy dolls.
Official. Sexy real dolls.
I mean, this is going to be a reality.
One day. We might not be here, but this,
I do think these are going to
be like iPhones at some point.
I think one day you're going to go over
your friends house and he's gonna have
this really hot girl in lingerie and
she's going to be cleaning up and you'd be
like, is she real? Shut
the well, it's like, wait,
actually watching him when he was like,
she doesn't speak English. Yeah, right.
Yeah. Wasn't she a robot at the
end? Yeah, I think she was the one.
The dancing Japanese lady. Yeah,
exactly. We're not going to,
it's going to be like on some
Westworld shit. Yeah, and it's coming.
It's coming. Look, if they can do this,
like they couldn't do this when
we were kids. This is a new thing.
So the amount of time between when
we were kids. Oh, what'd she saying?
She just said hi, my love. Would you like
me to recite a poem for you? Fuck No.
Where they're come from. I Dunno.
She's just listening to us.
Ask her how she feels about
porn. How do you feel about porn
baby later?
Oh, she's playing coy. How
do you feel about porn?
You know you can count on
me for the good and bad
to do what? What the fuck
are you going to do for me?
There's nothing you can do for me.
Telling me the good and bad mom. Okay.
Let me ask you a question.
What do you think about porn?
Not sure have to think about it.
Pornography is the portrayal of saying
she will subject matter for the exclusive
purpose
and then she's a fucking no at all.
Pornography may be presented into a
variety of media, including books,
magazines, postcard.
Now she's like a Shitty
Wikipedia. Yeah, totally.
She just turns into a
noxious Siri. We get it lady.
But it's funny when you ask her like,
hold on. Do you know what I
like about you? What? What?
What? Surprised. I'd be
surprised. And again,
you like my electricity. Keep you plugged
in dirty bitch. I, you can ask her.
How do you like to have sex?
I want you to do everything you like. I
want to feel you inside my body tonight.
Well, okay, shut her
off. I know. Jessie May,
I'm going to start throwing up totally.
It was so fucking funny,
but it's wild because she,
you can ask her like, are the
robots going to take over?
I could not find a good answer for that.
Oh my gosh. She's planning that.
Shut her up and I'm like that fucking
response right there in the water.
Short circuit. That bitch.
It is wild though because I do think
everyone is so obsessed with how bad the
sex robots, everyone's focusing their
energy on how this is why men are bad.
It's just like they don't, it's not,
they're opening up a sex robot brothel.
Where's that there? No,
there was one in Houston,
but they shut it down because people
were so freaked out and I was like,
who fucking cares? They
shut it down. Well,
they should shut it down because multiple
people are fucking the same robot.
That's disgusting for them.
What if they develop some
new silicone-based s t d
they wind up just burning
through the population like the plague.
I think it would just be like ringworm.
Dick bring more harm. I mean,
but also my thing with that is just like
if they're Weirdos, if they're freaks,
if they're perverts like don't you want
them all to be in one place? Right.
It's like monitor them like Scientology.
Put them all in one building.
I'm thrilled that they're all in a castle
on Franklin. I know where they are.
They're not in the wild
castle. I'm glad they're there.
I just keep them contained.
What do you think,
what are they up to today and
now what's going on? Jamie?
What are you growing it for? Did she
hack your software? Is the brothel.
It's in this one, I guess
is in Britain. Oh God.
Do they fuck them against the
wall? They're like urinals.
So try before you buy service. Oh boy.
Oh, this is like to test drive nothing.
Yeah, but you'd do it. They're just
out in front of everyone. I don't know.
Why isn't one wearing of tank tops?
So his British sex workers are scared
of a new breed of realistic dolls.
We'll put them out of business. What does
he do? Did he do a survey of hookers?
Yeah. Who is a non territory
in that time span or bonded?
Lot of European places. Who she looks
assume blackface. She's 10 she's Indian.
What is the, oh no. Oh, oh,
oh, Oh holy tits. Batman.
But here's what I'll say.
If would you rather your daughter at
18 go to the prom with a robot man or a
man? A man. Okay. Listen,
girls like boys and boys like girls.
Simple this. These are not bad.
I think the real problem is
making a big deal out of it.
That's the real problem. Totally
right. Why are people saying,
I just don't understand why this
is scary. Who scary is that this
is step one, right?
Like if you go back to the model a
and look at the model t Ford, right.
Something, some old ass car
and then go to a Tesla. Yeah.
Like oh well eventually it's
going to be this. Wow. You know,
if you could bring a Tesla till like
1920 and go, hey, you fucks look at this.
Yeah. This is what we're going
to have someday. My affinity,
I remember paved roads back then.
Think about that. Yeah. Yeah.
They didn't have anything.
Yeah. Everything was gone
so slow. It didn't matter.
But if you could get them in like a,
a model s and fucking stomp on the
gas where it like warps time. Yeah,
they would go what? Like what is, it's
like it's something from the future.
Yeah. So this is going to be,
whether it's a hundred years
from now or whatever it is.
Indiscernible from you and I. Yeah.
Wild. Yeah.
It was interesting and I haven't been
reading so much about this shit and a lot
of the problems with the robots and
the mistakes that they're making are
obviously the humans are
making the mistakes with the
algorithm because so many
smart people have to make dumb algorithms
in. They're like almost too smart.
Right. So there was Peter
Haas, he's a robotics guy.
Brown was trying to teach a robot to
differentiate between a Husky and a wolf
and what she was blinking the moon.
Jamie put pull, put you
got the camera on her,
get her to fucking stop stealing my
thunder and she just popping it onto
wherever she has some links
and moves around. Sorry,
she's stealing your thunder. But
she really is, what the fuck why?
It's like Penn and teller.
It's like when teller's teller starts
stealing the show. Like what the fuck?
I'm basically a ventriloquist
tagged at this point. Um,
but they were trying to teach the robot
to tell the difference and they fed all
these pictures of walls and all these
pictures of huskies and you wouldn't,
you would go, okay, look in the ears,
look at the eye color of the eyes,
look at the snout, look at the feed,
the tails, different, all that shit.
But they didn't know that they
had fed all the photos of wolves.
There was snow in the background.
So the robot was actually looking at the
snow and the background instead of the
foreground. So it conflated all the wool.
So they had to rewrite the algorithm
to tell it to look at the foreground
instead of the background.
Cause it was all these brilliant fucking
people that didn't think of the dumbest
thing. Right. You know,
it's almost the people making
it are almost too smart
to think of the dumb thing
that the robot needs.
Well the real question is when
are they going to be asked?
When are they really going to
be able to map the human mind?
Because Kurzweil thinks that there's
a group of people that thinks within,
they think 2042 like the 2042
symposium. It's like their,
their concept is, and I went to this
thing, me and Ren Dunkin for Psi Phi,
we went to this thing in New York City
a few years back where all these guys
think that in 2042 there's
going to be some sort of some,
some revelation in technology that allows
human beings to download their brains
into computers or download consciousness
and even make replicas of your own
consciousness. So we're
a mortal basically. Yeah.
Something along those lines.
But we're still figuring the
brain out. Yes. You know,
we don't really know how the brain,
we can't replicate it until we totally
know how it works. That's the idea. Yeah.
The biologists
have they the argue against it,
but when the Kurzweil explains it that
everybody is shortsighted because if you
look at the exponential
progress of technology,
even though we're so far away in our eyes
that everything changes exponentially
and within 20 years we will have gone
through a million years of technological
evolution or some other crazy fill
in the crazy number, whatever it is.
But by the time 2042
actually rolls around,
we will be so far ahead of
where we are now that it's all,
it's impossible for us to even
imagine the territory. Right, right.
Yeah.
Which is I think part of the reason I
wanted to like make her and is like why?
Why is the name of talking about laws?
Why hasn't anyone taught like no
one's really thinking about like,
I feel like like everything we, we've
sort of, after it's become too late,
that's when we start pulling it together
in terms of legislation and shit.
How do you incorporate her in your set?
I talk about robots for a good hour.
I cut it down, but I just kind of
realize like, I mean, you know,
it's like making a special, like I'm like,
if I'm going to talk about
fucking robots for 40 minutes,
some shit better come out
at the end, do you know? So,
but I went down to the sex robot factory
to sort of get material and just know
what the fuck I was talking about.
And uh, they asked, you know,
do you want us to make fun of you?
And I was like fucking that since
you know that the only main one,
I hope they're being sold by the
fucking droves that would make my day.
Which I did ask. Cause you know,
people request with sex dolls,
like specific celebrities,
body parts the most.
Who Do you think the most requested
mouth is? Scarlett Johansson? Nope.
I knew you were going to say
that cause I know you love.
No, Emilia Clarke. Who's that
it? Game of Thrones. Dragon Lady.
Oh, dragon lady. Interesting.
Most requested I's is Olivia
Wilde? Was that the um,
uh, she just directed a
movie, uh, called book smart,
but she's in a bunch of movies.
Beautiful. Beautiful, great.
You'll know or yeah, you'll know her as
soon as I'm married to Jason Sudeikis.
Um, that is either, uh, she's
out. I'm out of the loop.
You really just are in your own Echo Jay.
Yeah. There's your in your own world.
I didn't even find out what to Kashi. Six,
nine wasn't until Jamie brought him
up. I don't even know who that, oh,
the wrapper. The ones in jail. Oh, who,
which one is this? This is Olivia Wilde.
This is who the pretty gorgeous.
That's the eyes. And then I was like,
well has anyone ever, ever requested
or anything for Moon? And they're like,
yes. A couple people have heard
your fingers, eyebrows, eyebrows.
I want Whitney Cummings eyebrows,
like the least sexual thing about
a human being. My fucking eyebrows.
He nailed your eyebrows with her
though. Really? Yeah. Perfect. John.
I'm the sharpie. Yup. That's what
you liked. Like, and weird. Um,
but I kind of went down cause I
wanted to see like what was up,
like are they putting
nine holes in the chest?
Like I just fucking holes
in the rib cage. Totally.
Like is this some like insane?
They just put a golf course on her
body just like 18 holes of vagina.
I just didn't know what I was kind
of endorsing or talking and I was
just, I gotta be honest with you.
I was just so surprised at how um,
it was kinda touching to be honest,
when they were telling me
about what the guys ordered,
I was a little surprised that it didn't
align with where everyone's like there's
this impossible standard of beauty. Like
that's all you fucking hear these days.
Half the guys that ordered them requested
pubes spend an extra $1,400 for them.
$1,400 for just to have
manual, like a little Merkin,
like a little piece of do one thread
at a time. That's exactly right.
And then a lot of guys complain that
they're too skinny. They want bigger ones,
they want big thighs and big butts.
But the technology is not
available to make them lightweight.
Guys want them to be older. A
lot of guys were complaining,
they want them to look older.
So I kind of was just like,
this is sort of great news.
Like why is everyone so well maybe it's
because that's the type of woman that
would reject them. Older woman
who has her shit together.
Oh that's fucking profound. Yeah.
Whereas a younger girl doesn't know
what the fuck's going on or I'm hungry.
Hit My Venmo. Yeah. Younger girl just
doesn't get it. She's, she's delusional.
Yeah. Yeah. Huh. She
doesn't know her value yet,
but I also just felt like
there was a little bit,
you know when they were telling
me that I was like, Oh God,
maybe fucking guys are made to now feel
shame for what they're into. You know?
No one talks about the way that you
know, and I do a lot of my special,
haven't got a lot of shit for this cause
I basically defending guys the whole
time when he defend what he's
saying. It's just like guys,
I feel like now they're like,
I guess no one has pubes
that's just how it is now.
Like if you're a guy that's into pubes,
this isn't your moment like porn.
Like you'd have to really
go out of your way to find,
or you have to go back to like
seventies porn day to grow,
who's willing to grow it out for
you if you're really into it.
But if you're really that into it, you
should really ask yourself why. Yeah.
Pos. Yeah. I used to have
a bit about that too.
This is like Rogan's greatest head when
I was a kid that if everyone had pubes
[inaudible] it was a real thing.
That was a thing now like
shorts you just hadn't like,
I mean girls had ridiculous pubes
they didn't do anything about.
But now when you, um, uh,
what was that? Uh, when you,
electrolysis it, they, it doesn't grow
back. So I was to laser, right. Laser,
laser removal. It doesn't grow back. So
even if you want to grow them out now,
you'd have to get like
a little wheat. Yeah,
you'd have to get a little
some Minoxidil um, but I uh,
I was talking to a gynecologist
about that. He was like, yeah,
women are trying to get plugs now.
No where to God cause guys
are complaining about it.
Cause it's like women are getting
plugs, a little vagina, two plugs.
It'll grow long. Like
the hair on your head.
I guess you'd have to take it from your
head and put it down. Like, you know,
like braids, like Pippi Longstockings
Oh God. Like little braids. Cornrows.
Um, but so yeah, I guess it was just like,
I feel like the media wants to be like,
these are so bad for society just as cause
everyone's outraged about everything.
Now you should be curious.
I don't think they're necessarily
that bad for society, but it's,
it's unquestionably weird. That's weird.
But I don't know. I don't know
if it's that bad for society.
But getting back to what you're saying
about men being shamed for what they look
like and what other, what other examples?
I just thought that
was interesting. A nip.
Then there is like a wall of nipples you
could choose from and men are ashamed.
Yeah, no, it's just that there was
all different kinds of nipples.
There was long. The AB oblong was one of
the best sellers. Like I just, I just,
yeah, ridiculously long nipples.
Uh, oblong, asymmetrical.
Oh big dark ones
as a kid.
Loans kills 21 I did a girl had a wonky
eye [inaudible] and I thought wonky eyes
were hot for like years afterwards too.
Why don't you know? But she had like,
she had a Wonky, I like want
like straight look, look at her.
One of them was like a little off to
the left and you didn't notice it until
like you're talking to her for a couple
of minutes. Like oh that's what's up.
That's endearing. Yeah.
I thought it was hot.
I thought wonky eyes were hot for
a long time and she was hot. Yeah.
So it's like in my head it's like wonky
eyes were, oh Jamie put that away.
Just stop.
That gives life, it gives life that has
sustained the human species. Yes, sure.
Yeah. It's where the babies feed. But I
do feel like there's just a, you know,
you only kind of see one type
of nipple everywhere, you know,
and a lot of guys are, well I don't know.
I mean I guess I haven't seen
that much porn. I haven't seen no,
I'm thinking about it, but some guys
are going to giant areolas. Yeah,
that's right. That's huge.
Giant Ariel is are huge. Uh, uh,
dark areas are huge,
which is interesting cause I think there
is a biological basis for that because
once your nipples get dark, it's uh,
means you usually when you give birth,
your nipples get darker so the baby
can find the nipple. Really? Yeah.
It's darker. Nipples darken after
childbirth so your baby can find it.
Wow. Yeah, she was all
there. Blinken oh, I see.
You're never going to have the
babies that make you feel weird.
How did she might, you never know. Let
me ask her. Are you going to have a baby?
Pretty sure.
Oh, well I don't want her anymore.
She's going to have one of them
little alien chest burster babies.
It's going to come out screaming
and run across the floor.
[inaudible]
are robots are robots
gonna destroy humans.
Real bad skin. Not Harm. Give is bullshit.
Wow. That sounds like a
lie. This is bullshit.
I was really fascinated by this one.
Roboticists the coolest part about having
a robot is that I get to talk to all
these fucking roboticists
and who is saying that the,
the big fear with robots is because
they're all about efficiency, you know,
on this.
And there was that one study where they
told a robot to jump on the table and in
what you would do is you go, okay,
you would just jump on the table,
but it actually took more energy to
jump on the table than to just break the
table and push it to the
floor and step on top of it.
So it just went from and just stepped
on top of it. Oh Wow. It was like, oh,
the table, that's how we're going to die.
It's going to just see us as
inefficient. Ooh. And in the way,
we're going to just be obstacles. Right.
And won't see anything wrong
with destroying an object. Yeah.
But humans destroy humans. I ray
rather get destroyed by a robot and be
and cooler story. It seems so impersonal.
Like the moment when that robot sunk that
blade into that guy and ex Mokena and
just like a cycle looking right at
them while you're stabbing them. Yeah.
There was no change to her expression
at all. No compunction, no,
but I would feel better about it if
a robot killed me or I'd be like, oh,
wallet didn't know. You
know? It was just good.
You feel better if a person
killed you or an animal?
Depends on the kind of animal. Mountain
Lion. I have mountain lion and no yard.
I bet you do. How big are
the, are man lines big?
I've only seen two in the wild and the
ones I've seen were about 60 pounds.
Do they come right for your neck? Do
they know to just kill them? They know.
Yeah.
If it, I would rather I
think die by an animal.
Really? Because you'd rather
die by a human. I don't know.
I don't have a fighting
chance with a human. You do?
So I guess mine would be a little
quicker. I guess it depends on amount.
Really? Yeah. On your leg. Not Cute.
I have a fanny pack that I run with.
It's like a neoprene fanny pack
and keep my cell phone with. Yeah,
and I bring a knife that's strapped to
the Fannie per case of mountain lion
attacks. You. Yeah. I feel
like you're going to be,
I think you could beat up the
mountain lion. I don't think so.
Not without a knife. I think there's
a couple seconds that you have. Oh,
that thing grabs a hold of you that if
you have presence of mind and you can
pull that blade out and just
start seeing in its neck. Hmm.
Just just hacking at its neck.
Hi. Marshall would get it. No Marshall.
We'll be in seven pieces on the ground.
Smart is not designed for killing.
He can kill squirrels. I
thought we're done. I Dunno.
There was something I've told you about
when I got my Europe bitten off before
when my era,
there was a weird sense of calm that it
was a weird feeling of just like that
was fair. There was just something so
quick about it, like animals or something
so people don't know the story.
It's a dog you adopted was a little
sketchy and bit my ear off. Yeah.
And there were so bad. Was it hanging off
pretty bad? It was like,
it was so I didn't feel anything in the
moment that that was the good news about
that. And I'm sure if an animal
bitten to my, I'd probably feel more,
but it was like a rush of
dopamine or say whatever it was.
I did not feel pain until I saw it in
the mirror. Wow. So I'm just like, oh,
that was weird. Like it felt like an itch.
And then I looked in the mirror and
my first thought was I didn't put on
earrings today. Like
I don't wear earrings.
Like I thought it was
like a hoop earring. Oh.
And then the blood started coming down
and then I saw it and it just started
burning. It wasn't like a, like a pain.
And then I started
watching videos about, um,
people that got attacked by sharks and
there's a girl who had her armed but not
by a shark, Bethany something.
And she said that it like almost fell
orgasmic cause like dopamine rushes to the
area to get you to keep fighting
for your life basically.
Cause if you felt the pain
or you would give up. Whoa.
So I didn't really feel a lot of pain
until I got to the Er and then it started
like throbbing after like a couple hours
when the blood dried up and it just
starts to get uncomfortable and itchy.
But there was something that was so quick,
like animals don't really deliberate.
It was like funk and that
was it. Why did by your ear,
if I think he was just
trying to play with me,
I took it to an aggression specialist
and the aggression specialist was like
dog, this kind of dog gives you a warning.
They wouldn't just come right for
they growl first if there was true.
And also if that dog was trying
to kill you, it just would,
if it would have been in your face.
Right. So he probably bit, you just like,
look, you bet by the dog. Right? It's a
bit of dog skin. Nothing would happen.
But that same amount of pressure
that's our ears are useless, you know?
And it was probably taken from its mother
too young. Just skew when you sign up.
Sure. Her ear is, has the same scar
that mine does. We've molded that. Yeah.
Because of, yeah, we
molded my ears, my mouth.
Cause it's amazing to see
your scar. I can't see it.
You can see right there. Oh
Wow. But you did, did you too?
Yeah. It's not like cauliflower.
[inaudible] wow. It's ugly.
But all ears are ugly, I feel like did
not the best part. You know what I mean?
So I could get another surgery
on it, but I don't get it.
Yeah, it's years or fucking annoying.
Cover it up with your hair. Yes sir. Yep.
Headphones.
Ears are annoying as shit because it
doesn't hurt until six months later when
the nerves start growing
back in. It hurts like fuck.
So then it looks six months later
started, it started hurting.
I couldn't like sleep. I had to sleep
with this weird pillow and shit.
Just like nettlesome. Yeah.
I know so many guys that have
fucked up years from Jujitsu. I bet.
So my years at all? No, very little.
I've never noticed little
tiny pieces like this.
This is called found the
running. The rubbing. Yeah.
From getting him bent over and
crushed, getting caught and triangles.
But I always wore it. Your guards,
do you have to get them like,
like Brendan doesn't he have to get his
cutout or some shit if Brendan wants to,
he would have to get his cut and get
the the it's it calcifies. Yeah. Oh,
it's a card. Yeah. I used to have,
my nose was filled with that from my nose
had been broken so many times that the
inside of it was all calcified. Yeah.
And I couldn't breathe out of my
nose was useless, so I had to get a,
I had a deviated Septum to, so they,
they d they fixed the deviated septum.
They put the splints in there to keep
it in place. Then they had a cutout,
all the scar tissue and
all the nonsense in there.
It was like a laser or just with a
knife. I don't know. I was out cold.
I woke up and ah, but I didn't
get it done until I was 40. Huh.
I couldn't breathe out of my neck a
bulldog, so it was 40. It was terrible.
Was terrible for my cardio too. And
then, so if you wear ear guards,
you don't get it. Cause I feel like all
the fighters I see have that shit. Yeah.
They just don't, if you wear
ear guards, you don't get,
unless you get in a fight. But um, you
mostly you get in training, you know,
like a lot of Jujitsu guys
before they're a black belt,
they have fucking mangled ears. But
it's also like a badge of courage.
Like people like that they let you in
and also, yeah, you walk down the street,
no one wants to fuck with you, but
it fucks up the way you hear things.
Like if you take your ears, if you're
talking right now, like La, la, la, la,
la, and then you just go like that and
then you hear things, check, check,
check, check, check,
check. It's different.
Yeah. It sounds way different.
They're designed this way for a
reason to catches. That's right. Yeah,
the way that it's kind of, but it's also,
I don't recommend like
getting a surgery on it.
Surgery on your ears fucking more.
I've gotten so many surgeries.
This is by far the most painful. Wow.
The healing of the cartilage is a fucking
nightmare. And to anesthetize the ear,
they had to put the syringe in the
lacerations. So they were like,
it's going to hurt more
to anesthetize this.
So we're just going to do the
surgery without anesthesia.
And I just took a bunch of pain
killers and shit. Huh? Cause get you,
it's hard to get anesthesia
into cartilage. I know guys,
their ears are so fucked up they
can't get airpods in there. Oh fuck.
They just have a whole tiny pin hole
on this side of a piercing right there.
This was for cause I get
migraines and they say,
what's this piercing helps
with migraines? Jesus.
It's probably just psychosomatic. It's
some fucking, even now my Migraine,
totally. It's placebo effect is
in effect. I rely on it heavily.
But that was just,
that didn't hurt in there until it
didn't hurt when it went through.
But then it hurt for six
months after Jesus Christ.
Yours are a fucking nightmare.
I'll tell you what, but yeah,
so we got her ear Mulder
cause it's amazing.
I think something that I was talking to
this facial transplant person about how
it's actually really hard to get something
to look similar, like the bone start.
Everything's got to be perfect.
Like my nose is really asymmetrical.
My nostrils are really asymmetrical.
So they had to work really hard
and mold it over and over again.
How'd you nostrils become asymmetrical?
Is bad breeding really bad
genetics when you've met me,
my full face is I have a Bokassa painting.
I mean my face is a fucking mess,
you know? So to get, you have to
have the asymmetry down, right?
And they say the key to something looking
human is a lack of symmetry because
symmetry is actually creepy. Do
you remember that movie invasion?
The body snatchers? Yeah.
And not really Donald Sutherland.
Great. Yeah. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The movie. I don't remember
the wash it again recently,
like within the last couple of
years. It was great. Like real,
real weird too because it's a time
capsule because it's a time capsule to San
Francisco in the 1970s when they filmed
it really, really weird. But, but the,
the idea was that these pods,
they came from outer space,
they grew and then when
you had them in your house,
they would create a out a double
of you that would take you over.
I'll give you came home and you saw that
because it looks like you [inaudible]
but it doesn't look like you.
What is different about it besides the
lack of wrinkles? Not You. Shyness. No,
it's just not you. It's not, it's not
even that close. Well cause I have Poe,
it has poor is it has individually added
pores by you grab her and bring her
closer to you. Yeah. Bring her over
here. I'll try. Hold on. First of all,
here's her. So what does that
part or just travel bust.
Oh she has a travel bust. Just need to
work on. Just want to have the head.
You could plug in just the head.
Right. I'm like a little lady. Yeah.
If you just need her head for something
like bring her right next to you.
There you go. She, I feel
like get your head right
close to it. It's like the
skin tone is different.
They made her six months ago and
I already look 40 years older.
I did 50 cities and I've aged, it looks
super uncomfortable then next to you.
Oh really? That's cool.
She has to share fucking just
spotlight and she doesn't like it.
This I hope looks different.
These ratchet ass fingers I hope
do not look different fingers.
The whoop people can't see. It's like
the skin is coming off the finger.
Like the robot parts are showing.
Ah, this is actually compute.
The guys that buy these on the chat rooms,
they usually spend most of the time
talking to each other about how to fix the
fingers cause they break them off by
accident constantly and we stick them in
their ass. Yeah, exactly.
Rubbing them constantly on their taint
and it becomes like a car club where guys
are like three d print and fingernails
and three d printing eyeballs.
It's mostly just fixing them. It
becomes like fixing up an old car.
It's just like a hobby because
they break so easily. Um,
at least this iteration of them does.
But yeah, you can. I mean it's, yeah,
it's pretty fucking wild. I mean, she
can, it's noise when you do that. Oh yeah.
She's, she's kind of rickety. I think
she's awkward. But if you came home
and that was in your house
standing there staring at you,
what kind of a fucking heart attack would
you have if you didn't know that you
had? Like if you didn't have this right,
if you didn't go through all the
process, you went in one day,
you put the key to your lock,
you opened up your door except inside
your house and she's standing there and
like some sexy lingerie or in a bikini
or something like that, staring at you.
What fucking heart attack you would have?
No, I'd tell this show human. She doesn't,
I mean, but they will at some point.
She's just, she's like fucking a my buddy.
I mean she's like a ratchet. Chucky,
you know the, the uncanny
valley. That's right.
She's in the uncanny valley where it's
not quite a human where I went to Nvidia
wants there a video card, video game.
They make a video cards for computers,
like really high end graphics cards
and for Gamers and stuff like that.
And one of the things that they had
was, and this was quite a few years ago,
they had the state of the art fake CGI
person that you could kind of talk to and
it was animated and they were
like, we're not quite there.
Like we can't do the mouth.
Like the tongue can't
do the tongue correctly.
I'll show you because the muscles,
that's what's so fascinating is
this is this is what we looked at.
This is the exactly the guy
that we looked at. And um,
is this the video of the show that I
did? 2013 face works. You can look it up.
That's why
the guy, and he's also bald because
they, they can't do the hair, right?
Yeah, of course this was six years
ago. Right. But look how close it is.
Look under the skin. That's
pretty amazing. Like stubble.
I mean that's like razor burn and
also the eyebrows are really good,
but it's still uncanny. It's
still not quite a person.
There's something wrong. But that's video,
which is better to duplicate than
those wrinkles are good. Yeah.
It's wild because it does make you realize
flaws are what makes something look
human. We spend all of our time
trying to be without flaws,
but that's actually what sells
it. Well what do you, as a woman,
how do you feel about that? Like that,
and we've talked about this
before with wood, with guys,
guys that use filters on their
pictures. It is, they gonna say fillers.
Cause guys do that to do that too.
That's weird. Yeah, that's weird.
They're both equally weird.
But there's something particularly
disturbing to me about guys who you've use
filters. I'm the only no one.
I'm glad I'm not single. That's all I'm
just saying. Cause I thought they got a,
you know, but yeah, I mean it's um,
alarming but look, a lot of guys do it.
I mean guys are all skin fucking
calf implants and shit and guys what,
who's getting capital?
I don't think anyone we know but
caffeine plants are a fucking thing. No,
it's a big deal. Big Deal
course years ago. Yeah.
I thought that was a joke. I don't believe
so. Oh No. Never watched entourage.
People get calf and plants. Guys are
going face lifts, all kinds of shit.
You know,
I know guys are getting and Jay but
what they say suck dicks. Get Lick lip.
Yes. I would have different
things. I don't know. I there's,
I know guys that were guys that were gay.
There are some guys that
I was going on here.
Is this a Cathy's or
Katherine Plant website?
It's just Google images for Canada.
We got that one in the lower left by
the way. You could just run hills,
you pussy. But when you do
this can you still exercise?
Like can you grow muscle
underneath it guys?
Calves look very impressive on
the right. I do have to say,
I mean they changed him. Shortcuts.
How much of these, oh, those, those
look like tits that fell down.
Note those look like a cop.
Like an athletic cop over your
balls like a fencer. Yes. Yeah,
but to keep from getting kicked in the
know he did that at the fucking mini mall
and you see that?
That's a mistake that I about that guy
does a tattoo or those bad or good right
there. Look at this one. That's pretty
damn realistic. What does it hang on to?
It's what I don't understand. I used to
really be another surgery channel. Well,
I mean it's gotta be like silicone
silicone or water based or something like
that. But how do you live
with yourself? I don't know.
It feels like a tricky one. Do you?
Probably just trying to get laid
and your Saturday. Oh No. Scars.
Oh, it looks like that's some Pinocchio
Shit right there. I don't like that.
But what's the thing on the left? Has
it rotted? What are all those veins?
Got The implants to take
care of that problem.
I'm glad my robot's Lisa stirred
something. You've seen some injuries,
but you got bit by wolves. It
says why I got him and it says,
cause he got eaten by wolves. Yeah.
Those looks like tact slice right
behind his knee and just dropped him in.
But look at it as there was no other
options. Well here's the other options.
Don't get Caplin plants and stop running
around outside with bulls. Go good. No,
I'm just saying. Yeah, I don't
think you really got pit by walls.
That does happen. Wolves get you.
They usually get you get you. It's
very, coyotes might do
that to your calves. Yeah.
There's no like margin
of error with walls.
They just break the bones
or your leg with one bite.
I had an injury because it's a car
accident. He was younger and a,
his caps wouldn't grow. Yeah, I
think a lot of it's reconstructive.
Let's just one sentence about it. Oh
yeah. But a lot of guys get that shit.
I knew a guy who had peck implants. He
was a skinny guy. That's implants. Yeah.
You got peck.
Employee got the under his under his
meat of his chest to make his chest poke
poke forward more. And so is that,
is that something somebody does cause
they can't accomplish it naturally or
they're just lazy and cutting
corners? You'd have to ask them.
But the reality is there's things people
that some people are ectomorphs and
ectomorphs or like really thin people
that have an incredibly hard time gaining
weight. Their body just doesn't.
Yeah, it doesn't grow mass. The,
their muscles don't grow. Right. Male
plastic surgery is a really big thing now,
but putting filters on it, I dunno,
it feels like a slicker and love
that show botched. Love it. Let Fun.
One live for one episode was
actually pretty interesting.
Where's a guy who had been in an injury
and he got his calf destroyed or his,
uh, his, his breast
destroyed his peck. Yeah.
And they had to fix it. I don't
know. He just said nothing there.
So he had like one that was like, here.
There was a guy who was a fighter who's
a high level UFC fighters name is Trey
Tugman. He fought Vitor Belfort,
1997 he was v Tor Belfort's
inaugural fight in the UFC.
And when we didn't know about v Tour When
v tour was 19 years old and I knew who
he was cause I was training
with v Tour back then I was,
I was a white belt at Carlson Gracie
school on Hawthorne in a West Hollywood.
So we knew he was this phenomenal talent,
but a lot of people didn't know
that he was this incredible boxer.
He had this crazy hand speed.
He lit this dude up. But anyway,
Trey Tellerman was in a car accident
when he was a little kid and uh,
he didn't have a pack. Like
his chest was caved in.
It's very CV photograph of Trey
telegram. The guy was a stud too,
and handsome fella too, but
everything else just super jacked.
But he had this crazy peck injury.
Look at this, look at that. See that?
Oh fuck yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well he was a baby, I think,
and he was in a car accident.
Significant injury that
would psych me out. Yeah.
If a guy took his clothes off and
you saw that that's your opponent,
you're just like, oh
fuck man. But he, um, um,
you know, there's something hot
about it. There's this is, this is,
I think there's something primal of
like, he's fucking survived some shit.
Stick with him. There's
something hot about that.
Like that dude from the wire with
that scar across his face. Scars.
Any kind of proof of injury proof that
you've been in battle is attractive to
my, yeah, that's a weird membrane,
right? I hate myself for it.
Do you know that the Nazis used to have
dueling scars that were very popular
across the face? It was a big, they would
all, they would get them on purpose.
Like they would get into duels with swords
and they would have dueling scars and
a lot of the operation paperclip Nazis
that we got from a Soviet where we got
from Germany rather at the end
of World War II, when you know,
NASA took on a bunch of German scientists,
a lot of them had these
horrific dueling scars,
face purpose.
Now they would get in boarding school
and in military school they would get in
fights with swords and they
would cut each other's faces,
open them and meth and shit to where
that was more than me for sure.
But that was more the Japanese that was
the kamikaze is the kamikaze is as the
way they got them to fly into boats
and just fucking explode their fucking
airplanes.
The way they got them to do that was
they were [inaudible] out of their mind,
man. Fuck yeah,
but try to find a picture
of a Nazi dueling scars.
It's crazy because like some guys that
were hanging out with Warner, Vaughn,
Werner Herzog rather, um,
no, Wernher von Braun,
Werner Herzog's directly
Wernher von Braun.
The guy was the head of NASA when
they went to the moon, he had this,
these guys that were working with him
and these giant scars across their face.
Huge. Like,
like a ritual like to
show your pecking order,
which showed you are bad-ass
that you had gone through.
But it was a big thing with the Nazis.
And there's some horrific
photos of these guys,
young kids with huge gaping open
wounds here. Here's, here's the photos.
Yeah. Go Zoom in. Zoom in on
the uh, yeah. See this is a guy,
this is right after the
dueling cults. That's,
I'm just going to work on this. It said
that women found that attractive. Yup.
So someone guys actually would
do it on purpose. Oh yeah.
They wouldn't have dockers
sliced off their fucking cheek.
Well look at this guy right
here with the goggles.
Go to that guy with the goggles right
there. Yeah, look at that. Yeah.
He's got two big scars on his face and
they had the goggles so they didn't cut
their fucking eyes out before
anesthesia. Oh yeah. See,
so he's got a plate over his nose to
keep his nose and tack cause you couldn't
really stitch that bitch back on.
But they would take these huge scars on
their cheeks cause they would be dueling
with real fucking swords and they would
have these practice dueling matches and
then they'd have to stitch them up. So
these guys all had these huge scars.
By the way, when it comes
back to cauliflower ears,
a lot of guys did that themselves on
Purpley. They're stitching them up. Whew.
Um, a lot of guys, um, did that
themselves would smash their ears. Yeah.
They were smashed their ears
on. Oh, all the time. Yeah.
Well a lot of white belts that
want to be like bad asses,
they'd smash their fucking ears.
Fucking drip tail leak now didn't explode.
Don't they explode sometimes? Well the
real well yeah, they can break off too.
There was one fight that I
was watching once where, um,
a chunk of this guy's ear
cause it's calcified. You know,
it's hard if you're ever touched
cauliflower ear, it feels like a rock.
It's cause it's calcium. It's a
rock crystallize. Literally. Yeah.
It's literally like a mineral rock
and it's inside your fucking year.
Randy couture, who had these crazy ones
used to take it, grind it into people's
faces.
Like so he would be like in an a head
and arm position and it would shove his
bed ear into your fucking eyeball
points for creativity. Oh, okay. That's
when they exploded. That's Leslie Smith.
She was fighting Jessica, I and Jessica.
I cracked her with a punch and literally
like she go purposely for it. No,
no. She's just beating her up in,
in the process of beating her up.
She caught her ear and it was hanging
out and open and Leslie Smith so fucking
tough. She didn't want to
stop the fight. She was mad.
They stopped the fight and fucking ear
was hanging off. That was a long time.
I mean, not a long time ago,
but about four years ago.
Do you think? Um, I mean,
would there ever be human
versus robot fights? Sure. Yeah.
I W I can't wait.
They would have to dial the robots
down. Right. They would have to them.
Like when I was talking about,
we were talking about before the show
started that I think it would be cool to
have a robot that moved at like 50% like
a martial arts robot that you would be
able to practice technique on. So you
just would just, you'd basically would,
you would do is do drills, right?
Like you do like a Dutch combination,
which is a one to left hook
to the body, right leg kick.
And you would do it like while
it's in front of you advancing,
you'd put that bag boom and it would
have to like react to your punches,
but they would do
everything like 50% speed.
So you could take a chance of this thing
hitting you, but it probably wouldn't,
but it would provide you
with enough movement so that
you could develop patterns
in your mind and your body would like
synchronize with these patterns so that in
a real fight you would know what what
you would have. You'd have these things.
It's sort of ingrained,
like one of the things that happens in
a fight is things happen that you don't
think of.
You just do them and you don't realize
you were even going to do them until you
already did it. Right?
Because it's like you've drilled
them into your subconscious.
So you could do that with,
with a robot and then maybe you can ramp
the robot up to three quarters speed.
If he got really good at it,
then you couldn't really move and duck
and it would be throwing punches at you
trying to hit you
and they can record you so
you can see what you're doing.
Would that'd be helpful? That would, if
you could look through the robot's eyes,
you can put, just put a fucking GoPro
on it. They're going to have a eyes, uh,
uh, cameras soon.
Yeah. And then you're going to see
someone's Dick Holes right in the camera.
Log Out, locked up like a
woman. She's not even gonna
like if you see cotton horns,
that's the one thing about porns
is like the moment the load hits,
no matter how good of it actresses,
the moment the loads hits,
like this is always a brace for impact
is always a flinch. Even the most number.
Real pros, a real pro just takes
it on the mug and just, just,
there's, I don't know, like boxers.
Some boxers is photos of them or
they're getting hit with their ours or
whatever. They never, they never squint.
Ever since tumbler doesn't have porn,
I'm feel like I'm off the
map. Tomboy doesn't have porn.
It used to used to have
porn. It was super,
it wasn't one of the most
popular porn sites. What? Yeah.
And they stopped doing
porn. Do you know why?
Probably because people complaining this
making too much money.
It's too lucrative. Oh,
they were making money on commerce.
It was like a blog site and people were
putting all this porn and they were
getting shutdown. Well Twitter has
porn. Yes it does. I follow the ideas.
I'm fully fucking aware. Twitter
is a lot of porn. Actually.
I didn't realize that. I will only follow
fucking annoying us news. Bullshit.
Yeah. I mean I just, I Twitter, I'm just
like all my friends and news outlets.
I don't know if I want to like jerk
off in between like CNN and business
insider. I've looked at
Twitter so infrequently. No,
cause every time I look at it,
it seems to be, it's fighting.
It's exhausting arguing and you don't
help me cause I was like this special and
I loved your special because like
you acknowledge, you're like,
I'm gonna get in trouble for
this or you're going to be like,
that was just so fucking smart.
When I was writing this special,
it's the first time I've ever done one
where I started cutting bits because I
was like, it's just
not worth the fighting.
Like I didn't want to fucking
deal with it. You know?
Like I had this whole bit on Marilyn
Monroe and how I don't think she's like,
I feel like she's being forced
on us as like a feminist icon.
Like all my girlfriends were like posting
like photos of Marilyn Monroe being
like, you know, always show up two hours
late, keep a man waiting. I'm like,
this woman is a fucking
asshole. She's a slob.
And why do I,
why she's not my Gloria Steinem and I
just had this whole bit and I'm just like,
oh,
they're going to say I don't like women
and I'm to shaming slut-shaming I just
like, it's not even fucking worth.
But she's a weird one. Right?
Because she fucked everybody, which is
not bad. It's not bad to fuck everybody.
But she fucked everybody in.
Apparently that's the real conspiracies
of the Kennedy's had her killed because
she was banging and JFK and then she
was banging RFK and apparently she loose
lips sink ships. Yup. Can't
yapping a lot. And look, I,
I'm gorgeous. Good for her,
for making my back dad and making
money the way you had to, but I just,
let's let her be what she was. Why,
why, you know, I think that she,
that Hetty Lamar should get the
credit that she gets, you know,
I mean you talked about heading
your special fucking Jean bad ass.
She was a legitimate, insane, nobody
gives a shit. I responsible for Wifi.
People use wifi mostly to
Google Marilyn Monroe quotes
Patty Lamar came back to life.
She be like, so did my invention.
Did it ever come of anything? We'd
be like, yeah, good news, bad news.
We mostly use it to Google the horror
version of you. No, I don't. I don't.
It's, it's, I love Marilyn Monroe.
Like I just feel like there's this
thing now where, you know, women,
we can't criticize any woman ever
or else that we get in trouble,
you know? And uh, I think we
have to be able to call people.
Like I say in my special, I talk about
the difference between women that are,
um, does anyone have any girlfriends
that think they're feminists but they're
actually just assholes?
You know? That's so true.
And I know that I'm
going to get shit for it.
And that's like the men's rights guys.
How many of the men's rights guys,
just like, they talk about women,
like they're pieces of meat, right?
Like is that really men's rights or are
you just a piece of shit? Are you like,
what are you doing here? Did you teach
in people that they need to have rights?
Are you teaching men how to
manipulate vulnerable people?
And how do you have this kind of time
to even like, I don't even unprofitable.
Yeah. You know those books are profitable.
Oh, it's like a whole business. Yeah.
Those books. I mean guys give seminars
on how to pick up women. Right? Oh right.
Like the um, the game. Yeah. Diet
theory. I remember when I used to, I,
when I first came to la, like guys
would do that and it was what?
The try it on you? Yes. The
first thing you do, well they,
you're supposed to ignore
the, it's nagging, right?
You're supposed to ignore them and then
you're supposed to do a compliment.
That's actually an insult. Like
every guy, when I first moved here,
it'd be like, I really like
how your eyes are crooked.
Like it was like every guy would
make the same thing. Who is that? Oh,
that's the pickup artist
guy. Mystery. Yeah.
The game that he like the host
of the show, his name is mystery.
Does he have a fake lip tattoo on
his neck? Is that what that is?
Kisses. Yeah, I think so. Why
does he have two cock rings here?
Like lipstick kind of thing. All
right. Okay. Oh, the furry hat.
Yeah. So he had a whole thing he was
doing for awhile and then the eyeliner on.
Oh yeah. Okay. This is like,
who am I to judge Chris
Angel Madness. Um, but,
and then you would like,
I try to ignore the girl.
It was this whole thing we're supposed
to be mean to her to make her like you or
some shit. Yeah.
Well that works on really vulnerable
people and girls and treaty girls who are
used to compliments and used
to getting a lot of attention.
Well,
for men that are ignored and that face
rejection over and over and over again,
they view women as if not the enemy as
some s some source of negative feelings.
Right. Yeah. And for you to get over on
them would be to get some of that back.
Right, right. All those bad
feelings, bad encounters,
negative interactions that
you've had with women. Yeah.
I had a friend that was like that
over the time that I knew him.
I've met him when he was in his twenties
and as time went on into his thirties,
he became more and more
bitter and angry. His,
he wasn't very attractive and he would
have these interactions with women and
they would wind up, you know,
dumping him or abusing him. And he,
he just got fucking angry. And then as
he got older, he was just an angry guy.
Like he just hated women and it
was just because of rejection.
Like he associated them with
pain and emotional discomfort.
And so for a guy like that, and he,
he wasn't into the game
or anything like that,
but for some of those guys that are
vulnerable, like, you know, like this, uh,
this incell thing, right?
A lot of these men,
involuntary celibates,
they did develop these forum
groups and subreddits and,
and they meet up and, you know,
talk about what to do and maybe
I'll get facial surgery and yeah,
look no further than what
they want. Women. Yeah.
Ultimately that's a compromise. They
want a real woman, you know, they just,
they just got a shit roll
the dice genetically. Yeah.
I don't know a ton about,
I mean, I've read articles
about and said, but what it is,
can they not get hookers
or don't want to, or, well,
that's a problem because hookers are
illegal. Right, right. Like, you know,
if you get hookers, you got to go
through some sort of shady black market.
Fucking Dantanna's like go to
[inaudible]. Oh my God. Oh yeah.
That old Santana. Yeah. D Joey.
Joey Diaz was actually telling me
about that today. Nights at Dantanna's.
He says, yeah, Friday nights cock
soccer. Yeah, that's exactly right.
We will have you convinced you'll go
there with a fucking newspaper. This is,
no, there's no hookers.
You'll be pretending like,
I'm sit here and wait and I'll just read
the paper and they'll show up. Yeah.
There's no hookers. Yeah. Uh, putting,
I remember I used to go in the four
seasons all the time and people would come
me like, ma'am, are you here to sit? Like,
they always thought I was a
prostitute during the lobby. Yeah.
Four seasons in Beverly Hills Peninsula.
They thought you were a hooker and they're
trying to get rid of, yes. Yeah. Oh,
they'd be like, ma'am, are you here
to see somebody or you're like,
if I ever showed up alone because poker
is just like wander around the four
seasons lobby. Oh, how weird. The
editory little coyotes. Oh my God.
Of course I used to call my,
when we used to go to the sky bar across
the street from his that still exist.
The monetary on sky bar
exists in the morning.
So it's across some of this call me
store. Yeah. I used to have a whole
a bit about them, the
coyotes cause they were like,
they would pray on these guys. I was,
I was hanging out once when me and a,
a friend of mine and we heard
this conversation between
this fat balding guy and
this really pretty girl with big tits
and, and uh, he was like, do you coke?
Do you do coke? She's like, yeah,
sometimes. And I was like, oh
cause it's like they would
prey on these vulnerable,
you know, like, like a pug. No,
like a pug. The got out of the yard.
That's what it felt like. Like,
because these women would have this
feral look in their eyes, like when,
when you're down to fucking people for
money, and that's how you get in by,
and you got some cocaine in your purse
and maybe a few dollars and you probably
don't eat well. Nope.
And you don't have a lot of money and
then whatever money you do have you
spending on drugs or whatever,
and there's a feeling that you get when
you're around them. Like they're feral.
Yeah. Every day we're hustling. Yeah.
They're hustling and they're looking for
these vulnerable guys with money. Yeah.
And so that's what, you know, the, the,
that place would be the
place where they would,
yeah. Mondrian. I remember
when I first moved there. Yeah.
You like wait in line to get in and
there's a pool and occasionally that music
is rock.
They'd jump into the Pam Anderson
famously like got naked and jumped in that
pool. That was like the, which,
yeah. Don't, that's it. That's it.
We've already got, I've already
had a public fight with her.
I don't want to get you did. Yeah.
On the roast. She was on the um, uh,
David Hasselhoff roast and I
mean, I, and I apologize to her.
Did you say something about I said, uh,
I believe I said Pam Anderson.
You fucked Tommy Lee cared rock
and who's the other one? Go.
You Fuck Tommy Lee, Bret
Michaels and kid rock.
Why don't you just save yourself some
time and drink a vat of magic Johnson's
okay.
Uh, uh, oh shit. I said a lot
of shit about her vagina and uh,
oh yeah, it didn't go great.
I mean, all this shit.
Like I just got asked to do
the next roast and I was like,
I don't even know if you can
fucking do roasts anymore.
Like roast battles still exist and they
still go hard in the paint on Tuesday
night of the car. That's right. We
just didn't share this tonight. Yeah.
We just did it in San
Francisco and it was so fun.
But I still found myself being
like that peacefully. I mean,
when we did Joan Rivers, I
said, uh, Joan Rivers is so old,
her vagina has a separate
entrance for blacks.
Cox. We
used to just be able to say that shit
and today I would fucking be run
out of town. No, you just said it.
I didn't fuck God. And then, I mean,
I remember people used to
think jokes were funny.
People used to have a sense of humor.
I mean, even fucking Joan, you know,
I said Mike, Joan, they're all career.
No eye opening joke for her was a Joan.
I love doing the wrestler
Ish.
It was hilarious. Like you could, I
imagine a good sense of humor the best.
And she had such good sense of
humor. Even during the roast,
her face from plastic surgery was
so frozen that cause you know,
every time someone tells a joke you'll
check in to see if the person that's
being roasted is laughing to make
sure. And she like Kinda, and she kept,
we would look at her and like Greg Geraldo
was just fucking hammering or in the
audience was nervous. And then she
said, she's like, I'm laughing.
I had too much botox.
Like she had to subtitle her face so
that we all knew she was okay. But yeah.
Did the Breyer Improv once with Joey
Diaz and Ari Shaffir and we got barbecued
in the green room. I mean just
barbecued. We went way too far.
And Joan Rivers in her
television show. It was when,
when she did a television show
where her daughter was on TV,
I don't know what show it was.
It was a reality show. Okay.
And we were watching it on the,
on the screen and her face
looked like a Kabuki mass.
It was just frozen.
Did you see the documentary? No. A piece
of work. Yeah. It's pretty, you see,
or she goes and gets it and talks
about it. And why was she doing that?
You know, I mean my girl look better.
There was a lot, I don't know.
I mean look it, I definitely get
nervous sometimes and people are all,
everyone always like accuse me of
doing my shit to my face. I'm like, no,
you'll know I'll look like
a fucking moon bounce.
Like allery gonna do it
eventually. Yes, for sure.
Why do people accuse you of it?
Cause you don't look like you did.
Thank you very thin nose though. They
would worry that you did your nose.
It's wild because you'd think
I got my notes about my note.
Nationals are crooked.
I went to a doctor in Beverly Hills
because I had sinus problems for longest
time and he actually said, you
know, I, I can you have a septic?
What does it deviate itself? It's
like you have a deviated septum.
And I was like, what do you do? Like he
was like, we can get a nose job if he,
yeah, totally. And I never did it
because you know when your nose is thin.
Thank you. If
he did it, what would he do?
Make it fan nostrils equal.
Even though they're really asymmetrical
and it's like problematic and sometimes
in its problem when I do
something in television,
sometimes they have to fix my nostrils
and posts to make them even who gives a
fuck about you now? It's just distracting.
I feel like those things are there
just to find out who's really weird.
Like if you really freaking out about
someone's asymmetrical nostrils. Yeah.
It's just, I mean the key to most movie
stars is they're symmetrical. You know?
They're just like, you know, think about
the most beautiful women in the world.
Have some symmetry. But yeah, I
don't, it's wild. I mean I have,
I mean I talk about it, my special,
I have had surgery on my boobs.
I did have boobs done hollow, which
is kind of this might interest you.
The I, I was learning, um,
because I had all kinds of shit and the
way that they make boobs look good is
cause I think I heard you talking about
someone about the shitty old breast and
plants,
the way they make them good now is that
they put you on like a crucifix and they
do the surgery while
you're standing up. Watch.
So that they saw you were out cold. Yes.
So that they fall well in your mind.
God really? Oh that's so I finally
went to a guy that knew how to do that.
Woo. Yeah. It's a lot of fucking miles.
But, so I admit what I have, you know,
but on my face it is alarming because
it does feel like female Comedians,
a couple of famous ones that we know
and they age went down that route.
I don't know if it's like the same thing
that got you into comedy is the same
thing that made you think
you had to do that. You know,
I've read a lot of stuff about
like childhood sexual abuse.
Like when people go really
off the grid with their face,
that's like a type of dysmorphia or
a lot of people, a lot of um, oh,
psychologists have said, cause I've
talked to a therapist who's job is, uh,
in Dysmorphia to advise on whether
it's another surgery should be done by
somebody. Like if they're getting
dysmorphic. And a lot of times it's,
if you've had childhood sexual abuse,
you want to change your
face so that it's not,
you don't see the person in the mirror
that got to be like in some Michael
Jackson thing. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like a childhood thing.
The Michael Jackson thing was always
that he hated his father and he hated
looking at his father and his own
face. So when it's that extreme,
I try to like not judge cause I'm like,
oh there might be some psychological
shit that I don't know about for sure.
You know,
but it's getting worse and worse with
this Instagram shit because kids are
grown. I mean it used to be like we had
acne and we'd go to school with acne,
you know,
but now it's like you're projecting this
flawless perfect face and then you have
to show up at school with
fucking acne the next day.
Like also it's like people want their
face to actually look like in the
Instagram filter, which
is bananas, bananas,
photo-shopped it doesn't. But again,
it's a test to see who's fucked up.
Like who wants that? Not, not
girl, who wants that as far as guy,
like what guy wants that? It's, I'm
so confounded by what I'm seeing.
But like also you just want to look like
everybody else when you're young was a
weird thing is women wanting to be
super skinny. That's a weird one.
I feel like that's always been around
now. Well it's a new model, skinny thing.
It's because it's not, it's not attractive
to men. Like men like asses we like,
I mean everyone's different. Right?
But yeah, I like girls with meat.
Well cause that also
translates to fertility.
I mean it's like we want someone that
looks for sure and you know healthy. Yeah.
Robot. I want to grow up and
carry a couch with me for real.
That's really endear you want to grow.
You pick up the end of the couch
while it's moving over here.
Like I don't expect you to
pick up the whole couch.
Pink lot a someone though instead of
looking into the couch it's going to be
harder for you than me, but we
don't have to carry that far.
I don't know this trend of super skinny
because it doesn't really make sense on
like a primordial level. Why it's a model.
It's a model thing because for clothes
they want a girl to be a clothes hanger.
They want a skinny girl that just looks
good sashaying down the runway with
their bag of bones,
which I was reading like,
and I actually did like a whole like
paper on this when I was in college about
actually the reason that
fashion had, you know,
such tiny models is
because they were just,
there was a shortage on
fabric during World War Two.
So they just started making dresses
smaller and then models skinnier.
Like it wasn't, yeah, it wasn't even
really something that we wanted it.
I always assumed it was gay dudes.
I'm sure that gay dudes who
are into twinks so they uh,
can you say two weeks without
getting arrested? How's it work?
Just made me nervous.
Lady Cohen got in trouble for saying
something about twinks isn't it?
This is the whole thing. I can't,
so it's just like fucking hell,
it's addicted. Here's what did help me
though. I, someone was saying, I read,
and I think this is on your podcast,
I'm 2% of all people on Twitter
make 80% of the comments. Yes.
So it's on us for amplifying
that 2%. It's real.
It's not that many fucking
ball. It just feels big.
It's not the world you go out in the
world and you would think that it's going
to be just knife fights,
fucking antifungals,
this shit bottle and people have to,
when I went on tour after the
Roseanne thing, everyone was like,
what happened to Rosie? That
was so funny. I was like,
you didn't hear half the
people didn't even know about.
I know most people didn't know about
it and then I was on tour and this is,
I mean there's some stuff in the special
that I'm sure like blogs are going to
come at me for, but you know,
I was going around and talking about
all the stuff happening in the news and
sexual harassment stuff and
getting your ass grabbed at work.
At one time I was in Houston.
This woman does, he yelled out,
I was like a guy that
grabs you in the ass.
She went take the compliment and move on.
She's probably all drunk. She's just like,
this is such an la New York. Fuck it.
You know? So it was just like
jokes. This is a different world.
So many points of view that we're
just not, that are not being heard.
You know the Twitter point
of view is very strange.
It's like you have right-wing Twitter,
left wing Twitter and black Twitter
because we have three different completely
or in our little echo chamber and it
just feels so much bigger than it is.
You out in the world and you're like,
oh you guys just want to fucking laugh.
Outreach culture. How do you
end? Well, how will this end?
I it ends with mine
reading software. Okay.
For Real.
I think what's happening
right now is it's we're all,
we're okay if you say something and you
have a certain intent and that intent is
not accurately expressed by the
sounds you're making with your mouth.
I can choose to get mad,
but if I can read what
you're thinking then the,
I know what your intent is
and then we'd be able to tell.
I'd be able to read your face and go,
oh Joe's joking cause we're right
in front of each other. Right.
That's what's missing on Twitter. There's
no social cues. Don't translate texts.
How many times is a friend sent you a
text message and you think they're serious
and they're just joking. Most
of the arguments in my life,
so many times I'll send some, cause I
say fucked up things on text message.
Half my text messages to
my friends are heinous.
I mean me and Kalyan and show out,
but I can show all psychotic Joey Diaz
every week since the pictures of his
shit. He sends me the other day,
he showed me his balls for
like 20 minutes. I'm sure
his balls are unbelievable,
ridiculous, gorgeous. They look like
Kim Kardashians, but they're very rare.
But is, what is that? Is
that just, um, are they fake?
Like you'd have this Joey dios. This is,
let me look at that gigantic
log of shit. That's,
that looks like a fucking
cell. That's just, no, no, no.
I've seen those in real life. He would
leave them in the toilet. For me,
this isn't healthy. I
would go into the room,
not if I can healthy associate Joey
d Diaz with healthy, first of all,
notice that it's not even in the water.
It's on the beach next to the water
gives me the fucking Willie because he's
kind of big and he doesn't really
fit on the toilet correctly.
Doesn't break off. Why
doesn't his sphincter cut
it? Holds it in for anything.
His finger, the Calamari has
his finger, his loose sing.
When he lets it loose it's just like a
log jam that just got released like a,
like they opened up a dam on the river.
I just whoa. I fucking nightmares.
Giant piece of shit. So he'll
send me pictures of his shit.
I just held her hand by accident. Yeah.
I needed some emotional comfort sister.
Where, what are we doing sister?
Thank God he's alive cause
he's one of those guys.
It's just like whatever outrage.
One of the things that I used to love
about going on the road with him,
which is tragically he's two successful.
Joey Diaz is famous now so I can't really
take him on the road with me as much
anymore cause he's always booked.
But the beautiful thing was,
but he will be working with
me tonight, the comedy store.
The beautiful thing was
when I take him on the road,
he would open everybody up
like so hard. They'll like,
all the taboos are out the window by
the time I go on stage. Oh, oh yeah.
That's such a fucking great smart
choice. Yeah. They weren't before.
People like, he's so funny. Why would
you want to follow him? I'm like,
well I think that's in your head. Cause
I think if you're funny, you're funny.
Yes. I mean he's
definitely funnier than me.
He's funny than everybody has ever lived,
but he's also building shakes
when jazz on stage. He's a, but he
also, he, he lays the foundation
that it's, everything's on the table.
You know, he used to do that at
the roast was Greg Giraldo. Yes.
He would go out and he would just say
the shit that even a rosy be like,
oh fuck. And he'd go first. Well people
were, hadn't even had drinks yet,
you know what I mean? Like he
said, um, ice tea, you're so old.
You used your first residual
check to buy your freedom.
I'm saying, Gee,
is bunny like that would be like
his opening joke. Oh my God.
It was like five 30 on a Sunday.
It was like, Oh me, Oh my God,
here's the plugins your
first visit you, oh my God.
Like he would just come sort and the
audience wouldn't even know what to do,
but that's something he
was so fucking unbelievable
TV at the same time. And we were
right next to each other, uh,
on the lot at Gower,
sunset and Gower. Yeah,
I was a news radio and he had his own
show for a bit and his show was right next
to my show and we would hang
out, you know, cause we're,
we're both guys from New York that
were more from the east coast at least,
that were doing comedy and we're out
here, I'll tell, oh, this is crazy.
You know, and, and, and I, I'd have
thought he would die like that.
Like when he died of a drug overdose, I
was like, Greg, well he had been sober.
Yeah. What happened? You went to a
party and someone gave him some shit.
I mean, it's so tricky when
my, I mean I get worried,
I'm like a fucking mom about
this shit. What my guy,
you know anyone goes on the
road and you're getting shit.
You don't know how strong it is.
You're getting it from random people.
I think he had been sober
and his tolerance was low
and just tried to go back to
what had
that one was. I think so,
but I don't know all the details
that fucking need for escape.
The need for the pill thing.
Does it feel like though in general comics
are getting healthier? Like you pro,
you saw the days when everyone
was on blow and everyone,
it feels like everyone's down Jamba
juice and on it and Kombucha and the real
problem is I can't imagine
drinking money because of that.
You know? I mean I don't, Amy,
we've definitely lost our balls.
Some people think that
in order to be a comedian you have to be
at least a little bit self destructive,
like the great one.
You have to have good styles for
you to get good stories. Yeah.
I started going to therapy
and I was like, fuck,
what do I talk about paying my
mortgage on time? This isn't funny.
It's a problem. You can wealthy, right?
You don't have any fear of, you know,
your, your bills are paid
when you stopped doing desperate
shit and making mistakes.
You just have less interesting
stories. Certainly. Yeah,
there's that. But it doesn't
always have to be stories. Right.
But I also think its perspective gets
very skewed when you live a life of
leisure. Yeah. You know,
when you live a life of leisure
and comfort and privilege,
which most wealthy comedians do,
that's when they all start to suck.
Like when comedians have,
usually they have a few good years,
like they make it and then they have like
one or two good specials and then they
have some that just what happened. Sloppy.
Because you think they just
don't have to fight as hard or,
I think a lot of times I hear, you know,
people will schedule their special,
they're like, I'm shooting
your special night. It's march.
It's like they have you written it like
you schedule it before you're finished
with this, the Eddie Murphy
thing. Oh really? You know,
Eddie Murphy just got a $70 million.
He hasn't done standup in 30 years. So
like how many times does he get, look,
I think first of all, just
as an aside or just a,
to start this off, I'm not bashing him.
I'm a giant Eddie Murphy Fan of it.
Anybody who thinks that Eddie
Murphy should do stand up again.
It's me and I've even talked about on
this podcast that he did that he did some
speech on a podium where he's talking
about how bad bill Cosby fucked up because
they had a, he had to give his, uh,
his awards back, you know, I mean,
oh shit. It was hilarious segment. It's
hilarious. And I was like, God damn,
his timing is so good. I wish he would
do stand up again and just jump on.
He was at the comedy store walking the
halls a couple times on and on Tuesdays.
This was like a couple years ago and he
just walked in and he just like looked
like he was on a people mover.
He was just like float through the
hallways and you know the hallways,
it's like fucking bay
root in those hallways.
And I've always just get super quiet
and I'm like, is that fucking anymore?
This scouting hasn't done stand up in
30 years. That's how God damn like,
you know, as Nice as look, uh,
Tim Allen is Tim Allen hasn't
done standup in forever either.
But if he walks by or by his saw, that's
that guy from home improvement. Yeah.
You know, they're not like
freaking out that he's there.
He was so good during delirious,
like when we were kids,
you'd watch that you, but he
was so god damn good that today,
I mean Rockledge and of it
just carries on. I mean,
the real question is when he comes back,
are people going to start tearing
apart his old specials and saying, oh,
100% of the phobic and Oh
yeah, oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Can work. Like, well, you people
are going after people for George,
John Wayne, John Wayne. That's the best
ones. He's canceled his cans like, okay,
he's been dead for decades.
It's not woken up in the 70s you
said bad things about black people or
something. Now where it's like
Picasso's cancel, he's canceled. Oo.
Kowalski's canceled man. Like the
fucking, the costume was in Barbera,
whatever her name is. What's
her name? Hannah Gadsby.
She had a fucking thing about Picasso.
Like, hey babe, you gotta let that go.
That was a long time ago. He
admitted. I mean, it's like,
that's the other thing.
It's all these people who put their
mental illness and struggles on and they
would probably agree with us. Oh, for
sure. They were fucked up for Chanel.
Like van Gogh was shitty to his
subjects. It's like, oh, I mean,
you see it in his work. You know,
there's people that want to forgive
people though for things like wrong.
Remember when there's a lot of Roman
Polanski apologists? Oh, I don't,
I don't think I cut. There's quite a few.
Yeah, I mean they, in Hollywood, yes.
Legitimate actors
and actresses that were saying, you
know, it's time to let it go and leave.
He's an amazing artist and it
fucking raped good Rosemary's
baby's fucking great movie.
But I think he's, he,
he's done it. It's a rap.
But there are people like Stanley
Kubrick who is arguably the,
my, my favorite genius ever. And, and
filmmaking, which by the way, yeah,
I was reading that. Um, uh,
the guy that directed x Mokena kind of
loosely based the guy on Stanley Cooper.
Did you ever see, and then as soon as I
thought about that, I was like, Oh yeah,
tell Alex Garland I think is, uh,
that guy's name that wrote it.
I thought that was interesting. But
have you ever seen like the videos of
Kubrick Directing Shelly La and all
the stories about how he terrorized her
throughout the production
to get her into a, I mean,
he didn't want her to sleep. He
wanted to have bags under her eyes.
He would wake her up in the middle of
the night and he'd scream at her and call
her cot and then be like, I'm going to
be like, action. And then she'd be like,
fuck, like it was, her
performance is unbelievable.
And it's like ti was tear right today.
That would be a hostile work environment
to being olive oil and the Popeye movie
with Problem Williams and then
she just quit. Yeah. I mean,
her agent, she was so good in the
shining and then she doesn't do it.
Does emotional abuse make great art?
I don't know. It's, I'm not, no.
The same thing happened to Ricky
Schroder and the champ. Oh,
John Voight was like really shitty
with him. He was a little kid.
He was like six, seven years old.
Really shitty mean to him before
the scenes you start crying.
I mean there's also, there's a,
um, there's a director who, um,
there was an explosion in a
movie and the actor, you know,
it's a fake explosion and you're going,
oh, and then one take, he was like,
just make it around.
Just don't tell him in the fucking take
was amazing and the actor got all pissed
off. But the fucking work, you know,
you get to get credit for that.
So it's this tricky thing. Like I was a,
I did a show called Adam ruins
everything. You know that show. It's,
he's just a smart dude and he just asked
me to do a little guest spot and I had
to play a flight attendant in the fifties
who was getting sexually harassed like
that was the scene and because that's
what I guess airlines used to do that they
would sort of pimp out
their flight attendants.
If you were engaged and weren't allowed
to wear your ring, you had to be filler.
Yeah. It was like the episodes
are really interesting.
Supposed to be really hot. Right.
That whole thing had to be a certain
size and you had to be young and then you
had to kind of like, what did
they let that go? It was kind of
implied. Delta weight 235
pounds. He was five foot four.
Nice guy though, but it was like a
dating service back then basically.
And Adam did the whole thing on it and
I was in there and it felt very much,
everyone was like, okay, whatever you
feel comfortable with. And it was like,
no, we have to do that. We have to
make this feel uncomfortable. You know,
like don't worry about my feelings right
now. You know, it's like, you know,
so there is just this conversation
about like, uh,
no hostile work environment and everyone
needs to feel emotionally safe. Like,
well, can you, could you
make the shining today? Well,
can you get to that place
without being harassed?
If you're a really good actress,
would you be really crazy? Of course,
but I just, you know, you still have
to do it, you know, go for it. I mean,
isn't that the argument about great
actors that they kind of have to be crazy
like a Daniel Day Lewis type
actor? You have to kind of be like,
that's why they're method actors, right?
They stay in that mindset because to
maintain that mindset is really the only
way to achieve it. Like you almost
kind of have to be there all the time.
But also the being in character thing,
like when people like, you know,
bitch about like when Christian
Bale had his, you know,
melt their meltdown and stuff.
It's like, I mean it's just,
there's so many people on a set and
there's so many distractions and you know,
you at some point you're just like, I
have, it's impossible to fucking focus.
But then there's also,
there's losers on set,
sometimes it fuck things up and then
get in the way. That does happen. Yeah.
The fact that they recorded him
screaming at that guy, I was like, well,
I want to know what that guy
did and who was that guy?
That guy might be a moral,
hadn't he been starving himself
for like seven months or something?
That's the mechanic think it's the
same movie. It's just like, you know,
he's mechanical. He said,
I'm the machine and I'm the
face of this fucking movie.
I'm under all this pressure.
I have to get this thing.
We're losing light and this fucking
guy cell phone goes off or I don't know
exactly what happened, you know? But I
do think when Daniel Day Lewis is like,
I'm calling me Mr Link, our nobody talked
to me. It might just be his waving,
like, just fucking stop asking
me if I want hummus. Like,
just let me fucking focus, you know,
I think for like really intense
roles, which I've never done,
so I'm just completely
talking out of my ass.
I would think that you might
have to maintain some really
crazy state of mind to
get there so it doesn't look fake because
you know how you know how like you
see, did you ever see the movie
punch line with Sally Fields?
It's interesting to me, but when
Sally fields is killing, I'm like,
get the fuck up. Like that's,
no one's laughing at that.
It's not real. When people, when actors
do standing up, I think real stand up.
They're like, okay, what you
know who's nails it though?
That lady who plays the marvelous Mrs
Nasal. She's amazing. I love [inaudible].
I love her at some legit it does. Well
it's also in the fifties I think. Right?
But even the guy who plays Lenny
Bruce is great and I agree.
I haven't got show brother
and there was a, you know,
but like the one on showtime
Castro comics member,
Eric Griffin was on it
and now magical was on it.
That one on showtime dying up here.
Yeah. You know, just like Castro comics,
but the writing one that was like a
little shoddy dicey. But uh, but I,
I'm sure it's different for everyone, but
I do think though sometimes, you know,
you've been on sets,
like if you have to do a scene with
somebody where you're screaming,
you hate each other if you're hanging
out all day on Instagram and then it's
just like, it's hard to unfaced
like chemistry or knowing someone.
So I just think it's
interesting, like, you know,
Stanley Kubrick probably would be
cancelled today probably. Yeah.
Especially by people
who don't understand what's required
in order to achieve what he's trying to
get. Yeah. Kubrick was a mad man though.
I mean he used to do complex
mathematics in his spare time.
Yeah. Like as a hobby, right? Yeah. Like,
but he would do calculus and stuff like
that. He would do shit where he would,
yeah. I think on eyes wide shut.
He did like do 80 takes of Tom cruise
walk into the door and then I'll show up.
Like he didn't want actors
acting like he wanted them.
He wanted them in the actual state of
mind instead of acting like they were in
that actual state of
mind. Like he wanted that.
So he really wanted Tom Cruise to be
like exhausted and fucking pissed off and
annoyed. So he's like,
go piss him off and then let me
know when he's in that state.
I mean you would like
terrorize Shelley Duvall.
It's like kind of famous
and she looks, yeah.
Fucking terrifying. Yeah. You know,
so she's working with Jack Nicholson and
there's a great video of him preparing
for one of the scenes. Oh fuck.
And he's jumping up and down and
throwing his arms in the air.
Wow.
Like freaking out. You know, you can,
you could see him working himself
up before the scene. I mean he,
it's like those scenes that he did,
especially like the acts
through the bathroom door.
You can't just go into that cold.
You've got some of that in your
worked up. Yeah. It's wild.
Like I'm so obsessed with that movie cause
like the little things he did to make
you feel uneasy in a subliminal way.
Awesome. He's getting ready for the CIA.
He's like jumping her half and town.
How can she just, she's like, okay,
I'm in here and he's like, fucking,
yeah, this guy,
I don't know. Yeah,
there's nine people that want to like
ask him if he needs any hand sanded.
Oh gotcha. Oh yeah. That's a guy
with a walkie talkie going in there.
D is really dressed up like golfers
the fuck
and preppy. Azel it's
a great God damn movie.
You know that movie Stephen
King didn't like that movie?
Well yeah.
Well that's why they say that the car
on the road that's crashed on the road,
there's a red car in the beginning of
the movie that's crashed on the side of
the road. And then Stephen King's
version, there was a red car,
so Cooper crashed that car
and then it was a yellow car.
So he actually put shit in the
movie to like troll Stephen King.
Kind of amazing. That's hilarious. But
he did shit that was so fascinating.
Like little things to make you feel
uneasy. Like continuity errors.
Like he'd cut to a scene, there'd be a,
like if there was a chair
behind you cut away.
Cut back and there'd be no chair shit
you wouldn't really notice in case you
were like dissecting it. But
there's also a lot of weird references
in that movie to the Apollo Moon landing.
That's right.
Like saying that Weird Shit and
the native American genocide,
it's apparently a pretty big theme
in it. Um, but yeah, of course.
And the way that he, um, I mean
there's a whole documentary about this,
but yeah. That the carpet, the,
when the kid is riding the bicycle around
the carpet that he shot at both ways
and inter cut them.
So with the continuity's not working
and it just makes you feel, Oh yeah,
he was fun.
There's a great documentary. The guy who
followed [inaudible] around,
he was like his assistant,
he was an actor and he was acting and
something that Kubrick did and Kubrick
wind up hiring him as an assistant and
then he just did all Kubrick's movies and
hung out with them all the time.
It's a really strange, yeah. Yeah.
Well the documentary is
really good. It's, what is it?
Gonna do you know what it is? A room
two, three, six. One. What is it?
The last tape? I think it's on
Netflix, I believe, right? No, no, no.
It's the guy who hang hung
around with Stanley Kubrick.
It's about him. I think it's a
feeling more pictures. Is that it? Oh,
maybe that's it. A life in pictures.
2001 no, no, no. I don't think so.
Just Google the guy who worked
film marker. That's it. Right.
So this guy just sort of realized
somewhere along the line like, oh man,
I'll never be able to
make a fucking movie.
Like I'll never be able
to do what he's doing,
so I'm just going to start working with
him. So he's his personal assistant.
He started out as an actor and he just
worked with Kubrick through all of his
movies. Oh, wild. Yeah. And somehow
or another, they just click together.
So he wound up working for him. So it's
like, you probably don't know the name.
Leon Vitaly, scroll down. Please stop
you. You don't know the name Leon Vitaly,
but the upcoming documentary film work
or hopes to change that forever. Yeah.
British actor. Yeah. Stan Stanley
Kubrick to play the world.
Lord bullingdon and Barry
London. Yeah, it's a,
it's interesting because this guy sort
of devoted his life to like to work with
Kubrick.
It's interesting. Like, and
that was also back in the day,
I think Cooper would do like a movie
every for like five years or something.
It's like, that's back when you
made a movie when it was ready.
Now everyone's like movie every
eight months at noon. Well,
you know the apocalypse now story,
right? No movie took forever. Oh, right.
Yeah.
The movie took like seven fucking years
to make. Just don't write that. No, no.
That's a Francis Ford Coppola.
Oh, okay. That's like,
I don't think Oliver
Stone wrote that. Maybe.
I think he was involved in
some way. I don't think so.
I'm kind of obsessed with a lot of our
stone. Yeah. I wrote, I wrote a, uh,
my honors thesis in college
about so fucking Dorky,
the postmodern implications
of the movie, JFK, Da.
I was just obsessed with that movie.
Like at the right at the time we had it
had the most edits in any movie ever.
And the way that they just did mixed me.
I just fucking loved the movie and I
just wanted to write about it and dissect
it
movie. But the problem is they sorta,
he makes it seem like you know
exactly what happened. Right.
And the reality is we don't
know exactly what happened.
We don't know who killed JFK.
It was very likely that it wasn't Lee
Harvey Oswald though. Yeah, it did.
If it was that, if Lee Harvey
Oswald did take a shot,
he didn't take the only shots. There
was other people shooting yet. Right.
It's just so fun.
It was just so fucking blew my mind the
way that he makes movies. Pots. I mean,
I don't think we even grasp
the idea that someone shot
the fucking president on TV.
I can't, well actually it wasn't on
TV. I'm sorry. Do I mean there's,
did you ever, um,
what was the story about the guy
who shot himself in the mouth?
He ate skate song. Hey Man, nice shot.
Is that what that named
after? Yeah, that's about, uh,
and he was about to go to jail
and get a press conferences house.
And then he blew his head off.
He pulled out a 44 magnum and stuck
it in his mouth. Pennsylvania. Yeah.
Yeah. Pennsylvania. Can you imagine?
So that's on faces of death.
I didn't know that was bad. Then watch
that so many times from the nine years.
I could see it in my head right now.
So it was on and they just couldn't cut
it because it was live television. Well,
he gave a press conference.
I just put a gun in his mouth and blew
the top of his head off and they're like,
no, don't, don't, don't. He's like, oh.
And he did it like really quick
before anybody could get to him.
He just blew the top of his fucking head
on how many views that has on youtube.
Well, it's crazy. Like how quick the
blood starts pouring out of his nose.
That was one of the weird things.
Like, oh, that's what happens. Yeah.
I mean it makes sense, I guess for sure.
Just to be able to be that composed about
it. Yeah. He probably wasn't healthy,
but, and I think he was going
to be innocent. Fucking, oops.
I think so. Well sometimes people
getting dragged through the mud.
That's enough. That was why Bordain
killed himself. Public shaming. She was,
I mean, besides the depression,
he was terrified that he was going to get
dragged through the mud because he had
paid off.
That boy whose girlfriend had fucked
and he would had been so prominently
defending women and you know,
and going after Harvey Weinstein,
Weinstein in this whole
me too movement thing.
And then all of a sudden he was this
great hypocrite because his girl had,
you know, she had sexually molested a
17 year old kid and couldn't handle,
which is fine by the way. Listen,
there's a lady who just got off and
there's all this fucking talk about it.
There are people that, people are so
mad. Joey Diaz put it on his Twitter.
Nothing wrong with the good
Dick Sucking. She blew.
She blew some 14 year old kid and
it's on Twitter. One took it off.
Who took it off out there? I
looked at Joey's. What came down?
Twitter took a known, so I retweeted
it. Is it because of his 10 minutes?
Basically. Why? Why would they
take it? Deleted it? I don't know.
Twitter tweet them.
I just decided that it was against
the terms of service or something.
They're getting really weird with
stuff. I mean that's just a joke.
Well people are getting so does that
mean people snitched cause there's not an
algorithm or like a spider
program looking for that? Um,
people must have complained that. I
don't know. I'm looking for it right now.
I don't see it on my Twitter. Oh fuck.
That means it was taken down
if I was typing deleted it.
But he can still retweet something if
it's deleted. Right. That goes away then.
No, it's right here dude. It's here. I was
just looking at this page. Oh, you
didn't go back from, I didn't find it.
That was from this morning.
Bronx teacher who performed oral sex
on 14 year old gets 10 years probation.
Avoid jail teaching certificate.
So I'm saying performed.
It didn't take that long to get
the job. Did she? Four minutes.
There was a camera. There was
a lot going on. It was the,
it was a 32nd yes. Sloppy meth.
There was a lot going on in
there, but meanwhile nobody cares.
She didn't go to jail.
Everybody's like, okay.
Apparently a lot of people will commit
suicide after being on reality shows that
you don't really to hear about it just
because you get so famous and then nobody
gives a shit about you and you don't have
money. Yeah, and you don't have money,
Toby. Yeah.
That's pretty well to have that kind
of fame and out of nowhere and to not
really know why you have it and then have
it taken away from you and then to not
have any money. I mean,
think about it. Yeah.
The kind of psychological tests apparently
you have to take to be on a reality
show are pretty hardcore. Not In
the fear factor does. Oh really?
I bet they would just talk to people. How
are you doing? Ready to eat? Some eggs
were there, they were background
checks and shit though.
[inaudible] a few. We, we clearly
had some insane people on that.
You know what mean they're
getting paid $50,000 if they won.
Sometimes it was more like it was a big
episode, like they would win a million.
Um, we had one guy who won $1 million,
started speaking in tongues, so 11
[inaudible].
He was like super religious and he was
going to give all the money to like,
he was going to tithe 10% of his
money. It was like $100,000. Um,
and he was, uh, that was one of the
rare ones where they went a million,
but most of them was 50,000.
Did you get to have say and
the stuff that they did?
No, no. Say and I'd most
of the time didn't know.
I didn't know until I got there.
That's fucking crazy. Yeah.
Part of it was me, I didn't want
to know because I know your shit.
But part of it was because part of it is
because I thought it would be better if
it was a surprise to me.
So the day of I could be kind of more
enthusiastic about it cause it was so
crazy because some of the
stunts were so fucking crazy.
But there was a few times where I told
them to stop. I told him, don't do this.
One of them, contestants and
producers, everybody. I said,
let's not do this one, don't do it. And
they were like, you're crazy. I'm like,
why don't we had people ride bowls and
that was the first one. I was like,
you guys are out of your fucking
mind. This is so dangerous.
Roman games at this point. Well
your, they had a 98 year old,
a 90 pound 98 pound
girl. She was 98 pounds.
She was so tiny and they made a ride
the bolt and she went fall lying through
the air.
Just got so lucky that the bold didn't
kick her in the face and I'm telling you
it kicked up and her head was
here and the foot won't like this.
Just right by her friends. Is
that even legal? Like legal.
You sign off on the waiver. The
people ride bulls take a chance.
I mean that's exactly what happened.
And I was telling people don't do this.
And I told the producers, I
said, don't do this. Look,
I have had a healthy fear
of animals my whole life.
I was attacked by a goat when I was
like seven years old. So it was Hitler.
Really? Yeah. Hitler lost the testicle
to a goat goat in my is that, no,
makes sense. Myth. It sounds
is like a myth. As I said it.
I remember him missing I think a goat
bit. What it is. Nuts. Sorry. I was hit,
I was budded by goat and my stepfather
had to come and save me like a petting
zoo. No, it was at a um, a farm
co-op when we lived in San Francisco,
there was a, my step dad went
back to school and uh, he was a,
who was originally a computer programmer
and then he was going back to school to
be an architect.
And one of the things that he did with
part of his a university was they had
some sort of a, some sort of a
farming co-op thing. We didn't,
you had to take care of like certain
like farming chores and there was the
animals like,
like goats and I was a little kid and
then we got left in this fucking room with
this goat, this pen with a gun.
It was fine for the beginning and then
the goat fucking just came at me and
slammed his, uh, did it head worn
chest? Yeah. Oh yeah. There no joke.
And I remember I'm grabbing the
horns, but I didn't have any strength.
I was a little kid, you know,
I was maybe eight at the time and he
had to come and save me and I was like,
Jesus Christ. And I remember
thinking from that time on like, oh,
like you've got to get this idea of
what an animal is out of your head.
Like they, they, they, they, he
didn't, that thing didn't give a fuck.
Have I died? This is what
they just stomped me to death.
It would have been fine.
This is it. Was I right about that
or is that there could be a total,
Google's Hitler's, not Hitler
goat. Not Governments. Do you now,
there are two things about our algorithms.
It doesn't have anything to do with it.
I guess he had a undescended
testicle apparently.
And then he also had something
called a Hypo spatty ass.
Hmm. Something to do with, uh,
the urethra whole being on the underside
of the penis and not where it should
be.
Right. Or had a fucked up penis. Of
course he did. That's why I was so angry.
It makes so much sense. What nick did.
Did he not have any goat accidents
typed in? Go to this? It said rap.
What is like, I need to figure
out where that fucking came from.
But so many of the city was bit by a
goat in his younger days, but it's okay.
Been like goat. I didn't get his balls.
Howard is attached to his manhood.
I think every kid was bit by goat at some
point. Fun back then. Well, it's also,
it's like why? It's like
people always come in.
It's like all this us taking selfies
with tigers and shit. I'm like,
what are you doing right? What are you
doing? They're fucking Wa like you're in.
This is insane.
There's this new selfie culture where
we all are like taking selfies with the
bears and shit. It's like, use your head.
It's all everybody wants to do is
take pictures of things now for their
Facebook, it's like, it's
like the new fucking realm.
I think we're going to look back and
the same way we look at Caligula neurone
we're like, oh, they used to just have
lions fight elephants for entertainment.
Now we're going to look back and go,
remember when we used to like take
selfies with bears and ride elephants
blank and you'll have a
picture of things clean.
I think that's ultimately one of the
ways they're going to get us this.
This Elon Musk thing is
kind of interesting because
they're trying to put these
little fibers in your brain and it'll
have some sort of Bluetooth link that
increases your bandwidth
with the Internet,
but I think the way they're going to get
us as a hard drive that replaces your
memory because your memory
is so shitty. Yeah. Yeah.
I mean I have a pretty decent memory in,
in terms of like being able to recall
information and facts and stuff like that.
But if I had to draw a picture of House
that I lived in just 10 years ago,
I'd be like, oh, I can't,
I don't know what I saw.
But what about the things
you want to forget?
Like our brain is pretty good at
denial for self preservation purposes,
right? So what will you, how will you
brain, how will your brain handle?
Cause denial is a survival mechanism.
There are things we have to block out
in order to continue functioning or else
we'd go crazy.
Right? So like people when they're
molested, when they're young,
that's one of the things that they,
they have hypnotic regression
and then they remember it.
Yeah, exactly. Or EMDR or whatever the
thing is that brings it to the surface.
But I think denial serves
a really important part in
a lot of people's psyche.
Yes, sure. Or else you're going to
allows you to move on. Yeah, totally.
You know, so it's the I, that is what
scares me. It's going to be hard for,
I think, trauma survivors.
Certainly people in the military,
there's probably some shit
you want to forget, right.
You'll be able to access it over and
over again, like the bud Dwyer version.
Yeah.
I don't want to play that shit on a
loop and my brain brilliantly made that,
erase that. Yeah. So I didn't have
to think about it, you know. Yeah.
That's the one thing about that
that's alarming to me. But our,
our memories are so flawed and,
and there's this amazing neurologist in
New York called Morgan Surf and he's got
a bunch of shit on Ted
talks and stuff. And uh, he,
I went to this lecture he did in New
York about how our memories essentially
were like comics.
Like we punch up the parts of stories
that get the bigger responses and oh yeah.
I mean,
I've talked to so many friends about
things that happen when we're younger and
their version of it is so different
than mine am. I did we really do that?
I don't remember doing that.
I've had friends tell me about fights
where I did something to somebody and I
beat somebody's ass. I'm like,
I know that didn't happen.
Like you might think that didn't
happen. I didn't beat anybody.
Didn't I tell you about there was a time
that I was in Portland with somebody
and they were like Joe Rogan, him and
I got in a car accident in high school.
I remember I texted you about it and
you're like, that never happened. It,
I don't remember. We got in a car
accident. Guy was like, oh yeah,
I know Joe Rogan.
We got in a car accident in high school
and I definitely got in a car accident
in high school once, but we texted about
it and you're like, that didn't happen.
Oh was he had a crazy walk.
I saw one of you had repressed or
it was just while I definitely had
car accident. Hi hydroplaned right
outside school. I was leaving school.
I had a 1968, four, four two. It's
an Oldsmobile like a hot rod. And,
uh, those cars, like
old, when you hit water,
they would just hydroplane and I fucking
slammed into a tree or a telephone
pole. Jesus smashed the car, fucked it
up. But everybody wasn't gonna spin.
Yeah. Your car, you just, the
wheel just goes away and you just,
the car just slides. It's
super common with old cars,
especially if you don't have good tires.
But I had a friend who
came up to me or he,
he told another friend of mine about a
fight that we had gotten into where I,
I kicked somebody or something like that.
And I was like, that never happened.
I would, that never happened.
But he probably kept telling
the story and telling the story,
inflating it and getting laughs
on it or whatever. You know,
I got super into terror
management theory recently. Um,
it's basically like the guy that,
um, uh, Becker, Ernest Becker, um,
this is, my dad died a
couple of years ago and um,
I hadn't really had a lot of
death and I started kind of just,
I started getting into, and you call
it to one time, one day you were like,
you're doing too much shit. Like
you're doing too much stuff,
stop doing so much stuff. And I didn't
realize like when you have death in your,
basically terror management theory is
this is something, you know, of course,
but that because we have a
prefrontal cortex number,
basically the only animal that
can ponder the future in the past.
Like we know we're going to die
and we can't tolerate that anxiety.
It's too stressful for us.
So we basically have to keep ourselves
busy and do meaningless shit.
To feel important, you have to win
awards. We have to have titles,
we have to get things in order
to have a sense of immortality.
Right.
It's basically just managing the anxiety
of knowing that we're rotting every
day. It's just dying and
could die at any moment.
It's just like a false sense of
control and um, longevity. Um,
there's a great book called the warm and
the whole Solomon something. Solomon,
I read this book and it totally blew
my mind cause I realized so many of my
behaviors were just about this fear of
death because it had been sort of right
in front of me so quickly and his
death was so freak that it just, it,
I had a really hard time coping with the
anxiety of death coming so suddenly and
so shockingly, and like, um,
it fucked me up pretty bad. Um,
but I started just making
myself busy with super, uh,
relevant shit in order to try
to cope with that anxiety.
And so I got super into terror management
theory, terror management theory,
terror, like the trying
to manage the terror,
the daily terror that we know we're
gonna die, but the book, yeah,
but though it's still through
the core. It's something else.
It's a less corny cover. The one that
I have, but just the name, title, TMT,
terror management theory,
terror management theory is a little bit
controversial I think because it also
justifies some like supremacy thinking
a lot of I'm better than you and like
cultural um, superiority
stuff. I'd have to,
there's a guy named Solomon that did a
talk about it just because you need so
badly to feel important that you start
to sort of have the delusion that you're
better than other people just because
you feel so insignificant cause you know
you're going to die. You know,
we know we're a speck of dust.
We know this is all ephemeral and
fleeting and that we don't matter.
So we have to do things
to feel like we matter.
Oh that makes sense. Cause we don't,
so you sort of exercise your
superiority over people. Yeah.
In order to shield yourself from
the futility of your existence.
Yes. And to feel immortal. And you know
what I mean, to procreate, the idea of,
cause we know our mortality is so
present in our Amygdala all day,
every day that I'm better than you.
Therefore I'm going to procreate more
and we are going to sustain and propagate
so that we have a sense of lasting ness.
That's why we want to
make a name for ourselves.
That's why we want to get famous, have
the tangible things, stuff like that.
It drives, it's an anxiety
that manifests in materialism.
Workaholism needing titles
sort of shit like that.
Wow.
That makes sense.
So nasty evil people that subjugate all
their employees and yell at everybody
and like that's what they're doing. No
they're going to die. Wow. They know.
But then I even, it's so
deep in the subconscious,
they have no awareness of why
they're behaving the way they behave.
It's wild. They've done these studies
where, cause I got super into it cause I,
I didn't recognize my behavior.
I felt like kind of the Zombie.
I was like trying to like set up all
these TV shows and I was like writing all
these movies and I was
just like, and I was like,
this is so weird because my dad just died.
I should know exactly what matters
in life, which is none of this shit,
achievements or money or any of
that. But I was super into like,
I got to buy this house and
I need to get, you know,
this and this thing and this watch. And
I was like, this is so not who I am.
But it was me trying to cope sort of
with all of this anxiety about death.
But they did all these
studies where they put, um,
showed subjects of video
and subliminal messaging,
put one frame of just the word death
in perceptible to the actual eye.
And afterwards they showed people
pictures of woods or cities and said,
where would you rather be? And you'd
normally go beautiful woods nature.
And they always pick cities cause you
just subconsciously felt more scared and
wanting to be in a place that
was safer. Shit like that.
Cities are safer than the woods.
I mean just the idea of some protection
and you know, lots of civilization.
The woods are scary because we're
on some level know that we're only
superficially at the top of
the food chain. You know,
if we're out in the woods with a
bear and there's no guns or cages,
it's we're gonna lose.
It's like the idea that we just
know how vulnerable we are.
That's interesting because I would feel
like there's some anxiety attached to
the overpopulation aspect
to cities for sure.
There's gotta be some of that right?
Cars and the noise, the noise.
We're not designed for that. Right.
[inaudible] the fight or flight.
We're always in fight or
flight mode basically.
Do you ever get a chance to go to places
where there's no cell phone service and
you're in like the legitimate forest?
Ari's trying to get me to do the month.
No cell phone. Ariza Weirdo. Don't
listen to that guy. He's crazy.
I'm like, that feels a
little extreme. But yeah,
he's got the fucking flip phone thing
going on. But he's a real junkie.
Like he had a problem with food. He was
eating candy like all day every day.
And I was going, Bro, what are you
Dylan? Nah, a few years ago. Yeah,
years back. But he was just like,
he had a real problem with candy just
like Ra develops these things and uh,
he would get real obsessed
with social media. You know,
he was and realized it's
fucking addictive. Yeah.
I have an addictive personality. I fucking
get it. But I'm trying, I'm trying.
I'm trying to, I did the, I turn
the colors off on the phone.
Let me see what it looks like.
No I don't have it now because I was
fucking posting cause my thing came out
today. But they say a lot of the reason
it's so addictive is all the colors.
So you can put it in gray
scale. So it's black and white.
There's a phone that they just
released as an android phone.
That's all in gray scale.
It's like in that white paper shit
that you get like from a kindle.
That's what I need. It's so unbiased.
It's so fucking on appealing.
You're just like, oh fuck this gross.
So I'm trying to do that shit too.
Cause it's, it's, I think that
we're going to look back at this,
the way we look, look at
cigarettes. And if I think so too,
we're going to be like,
people used to use those.
I broke my phone in
Hawaii last year and uh,
it was like three days to get a new one.
I had to order one and get it sent to
me from the mainland. And you know,
I was on vacation and I was a bow hunting.
So it was just tracking animals all day
with no phone. Which one's in Hawaii?
Lanai. Oh cool. I mean what
animals access deer. Oh, cool.
It's m d of the state of to India.
And they're overpopulated in Lanai.
There's thousands of them. There's
20,000 deer and 3000 people.
You've never seen anything
like it. It's fucking crazy.
And they have to hunt them.
It's like one of the places on the
planet where there's a real ethical
imperative to, to hunt these
animals cause there's no predators.
So the only way they control their
populations is through hunting.
That's the only way.
And if there's ever a population they
graze and there's no food problem.
I mean there's plenty of
food. It's a tropical island.
But the problem is that you run into
this real possibility of disease and you
know it's just not good. But the,
the point being I was there for a solid
three days with no phone and it was this
weird feeling of peace. Fuck. It's like,
it calmed me down in this weird way.
It's like the desire to check.
Let me check my email real quick.
Let me look at my photos. Which one? Well,
I had to post something on Instagram.
I'm gonna check my Twitter, see if
somebody send me a direct message.
Let me see if anybody sent me any
pictures that I want to look at.
Know like Joey sent me any of his shit.
Joey sent me La something that is so
it's like such an obvious solution,
but I realized so much of going to the
phone is to check time and we have to,
it's like the new pocket watch and
then once you go to look at the time,
then you see your text message and
you know what I mean? Wear a watch.
I don't and I need to,
it was just where I'm going to start
to wear a watch and then also getting a
separate camera cause so much of what
we do is to take pictures. It's like,
Oh I got to take pictures of this
and then I'm on my phone. These,
this with a flip phone. Woo Pig Paul.
I know my heart just
stopped me a second. I'm not going to
post on Instagram with a flip phone.
Him Yelling on tick tock
tick tock tick, tick tock.
Oh I know about it from my kids. They
do the tick. Don't know what it is.
It's like live streaming
dancing. From what I understand,
I know it only from Christina's
page cause she puts on some,
oh it started as a music
app called musically.
It changed the name to Tiktaalik and
people just dancing. It's a lot of kids.
Kids are all over it but you
don't want to talk or be funny.
It's now become what vine was,
but it's still based around music.
It wasn't vine only like five
seconds. This is a little bit longer,
but there's a lot of songs over the
last year that have gotten popular off
there, including like old town road,
which was the number one song
got popular off of there.
That's how it got popular. Yeah. Wow.
Well I've got popular
with my kids for sure.
My kids knew about that song way
before me. They were singing it.
You never see that there's
a video of little nas x,
whatever his name is at a school and
he's on stage and these kids are seeing
along. It is fucking adorable.
They're all singing along to the song.
It's really cute. Good Song.
He's doing well mentally partner thing
and what was this? The controversy.
They wouldn't let the song
be on the country charts.
That was the big controversy race.
That's fucking racist. That's all it is.
That is like God damn country
song and not Garth Brooks,
that other Guy Cyrus is
oddly ray. Yeah, well they,
once they put him on then it, they
allowed it on the country charts.
He wasn't in the original version,
so they had to put him on it and then
it made me, am I wrong about that?
You are correct, but who do you
hoodie was this hunt country singer?
Yes.
But he started out as a regular
singer and then came over to country.
His career kind of fell apart as was
a pot and the bloke fish went away.
Derrius Rutger? Yes. Thank
you. He's really good.
Was fucking got a beautiful voice and
all the things I remember and he maybe he
just, that's his shit. He's into it.
But his career was floundering in the
other world and then he went into the
world of Hay and flannel
and they took off.
I fucking drive home to
a lot of his music hall.
I don't know why that Hootie and
the blowfish was a legit jam.
I wonder why they didn't last right there
on to Oregon right now who didn't get
it back. I was going to
say about Aaron Lewis.
Ms Stand also is a country singer.
Oh, he's in a huge country. So anyway,
he's got, he wears mag hats and he's got
don't tread on me tattooed on his neck.
That was like during the time
of him nice guy were like,
all the bands were like, Huh?
Like there was like a [inaudible].
There was a moment where that's what
all the music sound like and maybe that
just like trained toad,
the wet sprocket. Yeah.
That's all that. Like the fucking,
they was just got sick of it. The band.
But Pearl Jam, they're all pearl jam
phones best. That's what it is. They all
totally. Um, but yeah,
I think your phone a better man. Such
a good song. Yeah, it's great song.
I love the sound so good.
I mean that is so crazy.
When I think about that Jeremy
Spoken Song, I had no idea.
Like it was so weird when it came out.
I had no concept of what it even
fucking meant. I was listening,
it was on mixed the other day and I was
like, God, what was it about suicide?
Didn't it? Was it about a kid that,
that blew his head off in
Jeremy's spoken class today?
I think he blew his brains out in class
member that videos for consider story.
It's about suicide. Jesus used
to make out to a suicide song.
I had no idea what he was even about.
There's a lot of really McCobb
shit going on back down with music.
Remember that was that silver chair?
Remember that silver chair
video rape me about that?
Literally forgot about it
until just this moment rape me.
My friend used to dance to it. She
used to drink to it, smoke weed to it.
We used to sing along. If it was on
ticktack now we'd be singing along to it.
What a crazy fucking wild.
Who would be the Kurt Cobain of t like
what? That was such a big deal. Like who?
They can't have that with the Internet.
They would, someone would meet to them.
They'd find out shit about 'em. There'd
be a dick pic. Yep. People get angry.
I mean he had poor judgment. He dated
Courtney love. He married her. Right.
But like when he killed himself,
definitely taken pictures of his dog.
Who's that big right now?
Who's that big of a star?
There's so many stars now.
I think we've diluted the pool and there
are so many stars we've never heard of.
It used to be like there was a star
we all knew about were old funk.
That's part of the people that someone,
I'm like, Oh, who's that person?
They have 70 million followers. I'm
like, I've never heard of um, what? Yeah,
what? Yeah, we're out of the loop.
I'm way more out of the loop than you.
He's more in the loop than both of us.
Do you think that changes in a couple
of weeks when they take the follower
accounts off of like the
[inaudible] was only in Australia.
They're testing it in other
countries before they drop it here.
That looks like it looks like fucking
like they try drugs out in other countries
to shine out the follower count
thing. What? That's going to be weird.
Wonder what, how people go.
Why are they doing that?
Because they feel like they're doing
a disservice to people by having them
compete.
Psychology has it. Yeah. Yeah. You
won't be seeing other people's stuff.
So it might tell a lot of people
make money. I know, not me.
I don't ever do ads on Instagram, but
a lot of people do. I don't either.
I bet you get offered to
do a ton of shit a lot.
But I say no because you just think
it's corny. Yeah, I'll do ads ads
for things I like where um,
I put it up for free. Yeah.
But I've never been paid. Yeah. Like
if someone said, oh it's fucking owed.
Like maybe it is an ad but it's
not an ad I'm getting paid for.
Like if I find something that's cool I'll
just put it up like this is a bad ass
little video. This is how much
I think it helps. And I've,
I've been offered a lot of money
multiple times to do ads for things on
Instagram and I'm like, look, I do ads
my podcast, everybody knows it's an ad.
Yeah. If I'm doing, I'm not doing
that on Instagram. I'm just,
that doesn't seem like it makes sense.
Like if someone goes to your Instagram,
they want to see cool shit
that you're interested in,
they want to see a picture of something.
I want to see a picture of my dog or
food or fucking sunset or a mountain or
whatever the fuck it is.
They don't want to see sneakers
that your salad unless it's like,
but if it's a friend of mine
sneakers and he sell them,
I'll take a picture of that and put
it up, but I don't want any money.
I think it feels Corny, you
know? I think for you especially,
I think people trust you so much and
you're known for telling the truth and not
selling out. If you had a Hashtag
ad everyone was like, what?
Like it just feels paid ads. Well, it's
like your thing. It would just be like,
make a good product.
I'll post about it. Yeah.
For free all the time. Yeah.
I really do. And people,
I don't even know if they have
something cool, I'll put it up.
Yeah. Have you ever felt like, oh
fuck, that's a lot of money. No,
it's not worth it because you
probably lose in the long run.
Yeah. It's like if I was poor, yeah,
I would do it. Yeah. If I was poor,
I'd do it. I did fear factor. Fuck,
I'll do a lot of horse shit. That's not,
I'm not above whoring myself, but I'm not
going to whore myself if I have money.
No, that doesn't make any sense.
But that is weird cause I
wonder how people are gonna
a lot of people make money
from putting ads on Instagram.
Just delete it. I did not,
it's not related directly to this,
but they deleted a bunch of accounts
apparently yesterday count's had had up to
13 million followers. Really?
Meme accounts and shit.
The whole account for their book.
A couple of reasons they might have
done it like with a lot of meme accounts
that steal jokes
a lot. A lot hot la
crazy me. Just make money off of it.
There was a girl you saw that girl on a,
is it meg? Right?
Who was calling out that a fuck Jerry
Guy who was just doing comics jokes.
It was out. His name was may, I don't
know Mike. Right? Oh she was a uh,
comic comedy person. Yeah. Oh,
who bake comedy writer. Yeah.
And who was just like connecting
the comics joke to the meme.
So many that were at least they slowed
down like the progress of that fat Jewish
guy that's slowed down.
He doesn't have nearly the sort
of trajectory he used to have,
but that was all what he was about.
It's just like taking people's Shit and
repurposing it and making a lot of money
and then also like getting
on television shows,
being interviewed and not
having a fucking talent at all.
Just reposting. Yeah,
I know I people DM me all the time, Hey,
can I act now that everyone's scared that,
can I use your tweet in my Instagram
for you getting now I have to do work to
say yes so you can upper, you
know it's just like, but yeah,
a lot of people are like curators
I think is what they call it.
Is that why they deleted
them? Right. For coffee.
But article had said that there's like
they could have been taking advertising
money and not saying it and I'm like
cutting in at a Instagram's advertising
deals, reposting people, Shit, all that.
All that end of articles said that there
is no way they can get those accounts
back. There's, it's like
non-negotiable. Oh Shit. Oh fuck off.
But so we'll to basically go,
everyone's going to have no followers.
You won't be able to see it.
You'll be able to see your account.
Like you'll know that you still have it
every day I'm going to post an
Instagram photo of my account.
I got people are going to get their
Nas bitches recognize cause like,
I mean people are fucking falling off
cliffs taking selfies. Have you seen it?
It's like the fucking Darwin Award.
You'll still be able to see the likes.
You just won't be able to see your
followers yet either. None of it.
You'll be able to see how many
likes you have on your photos. Wow.
I'm going to pull your a screen, grab
it and posted. I'm going up my, my,
what I'll do is I'll post something
in the morning and then three times
throughout the day I'll post it to see
which, how many likes I got to everybody.
That's for sure going to
happen. Gangster moved though.
Instagram would be so mad at you.
You're fucked by bypassing like showing
your like some movement on your Twitter
account. Yeah.
Oh that's the move posted on my Twitter
account posted on my Facebook cause
that's a dumpster. If Facebook's a
dumpster, I just, I don't even look good.
Yeah, I mean just dump
things over there. Yeah.
It doesn't yours just connect to it.
Like it just automatically posts.
But it's interesting because it's
clearly reflects my lack of interaction
because like I only have 2 million
Facebook followers whereas like everything
else is way more than that
whole engagement thing now.
So there was this I social media
is this to its full time job.
So I was talking to much people to
run my social media and they're like,
well you have to engage people
to all to get in the algorithm.
Now you have to ask,
you have to ask questions so
that people like you notice it.
Celebrities for a while kept going like,
so what are you doing this weekend?
Like as if just thought they were
dumb. Like what do you like to cook on,
you know, Taco night. Like,
oh it was all these like
insincere questions cause
they wanted people to answer
so they could get into the
algorithm. Oh, that makes sense.
I read one that said, what's
your least favorite chore?
What in the fuck are you? What are
you, it's the amount of robots.
If you can't, um, if
you, if you, by the way,
the shot of this is so funny cause she
just looks like a dead body done with us.
She checked out, she was with us for
awhile now our neck. Fuck she's off.
Oh cause I didn't have her on chat
cause she kept stealing my thunder and
distracting your back bitch there.
She's back. [inaudible] over here.
Hey that bitch, um, I gotta end this.
I gotta be at the comedy
store in two hours.
Oh fuck am I gotta go home and hug my
kids. You have to go parents. All right.
We comings your new Netflix special
available right fucking now don't worry
about following me cause followers
don't matter anymore. Do not matter.
Don't like any of our like doesn't
mean anything. All right, bye.
Everybody go resuscitate this robot.
Okay.
[inaudible].